there's no time
[Music]
o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on oh my God
this is the main show it's Wednesday
already yes it is and holy crap I know I
hate to tell you this Zach but I was
gonna talk about Heaven's Gate but
that's not one of the ones I'm going to
talk about well the thing about it
there's so many it was like really hard
for me to narrow it down
I mean when I was like doing the
research for it I was like holy crap
there are so many that had like terrible
things happen like um our friend Dave
who's here hi Dave by the way
um you know mentioned Twilight Zone The
Movie you know where Vic Morrow got uh
killed and those two kids got killed
like in the hell with the helicopter
crash and everything like that but the
thing about it is like I wanted to cover
movies that
I don't know I don't know if this is
gonna be like I was trying to think of
some parameters I was like I want to
cover movies for like a bunch of stuff
went wrong and also movies that we
hadn't really talked about before
because the thing about it is like one
of the most famous like troubled
Productions behind the scenes was
Apocalypse Now obviously but we just
reviewed Apocalypse Now like not too
long ago and I think we went into like a
lot of that stuff so I didn't really
want to like repeat a lot of information
I wanted to kind of focus mostly on
movies that we hadn't really talked
about
um you know and stuff and I was thinking
about doing Heaven's Gate that was one
of the ones that was in consideration
but then I was like um some of the other
ones I feel like had more [ __ ] go wrong
and like more really bad [ __ ] go wrong
you know what I mean yeah because
there's I mean there was just so many I
was thinking about doing Ishtar too
because where they but that's the thing
I was well because they kind of when I
was a kid they kind of like shot that in
the middle of like a a really bad like
War it was it was like the PLO and like
something or something like that and
like they like Dustin Hoffman was like
they somebody said they were gonna he
was gonna get kidnapped and like all
this other kind of [ __ ] and then I was
thinking well maybe I should just do
movies that were [ __ ] shows behind the
scenes but like the but turned out great
movies I said that would kind of narrow
it down but then there was like some
stuff that I kind of wanted to talk
about that were maybe not so great
movies like you know what I mean like
the 1996 island of Dr Moreau which I
don't think is a great movie but that
was like very famously I liked it though
such a [ __ ] show behind the scenes that
they made a whole documentary about it I
still liked it and then that same
director came back to do Colorado
Colorado space Yeah that poor guy
Richard Stanley well his experience on
that movie which we'll get into because
that's one of the main ones I wanted to
talk about but his experience during
that movie like yeah I think he had a
nervous breakdown and like he was like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] and like went out in the
[ __ ] desert and lived down there for
like a long time and [ __ ] like that I
mean you know so it was like I said it
was hard to narrow it down
so hopefully
um you know and I I think I have more
material than I probably need like you
know what I mean like I have a couple at
the beginning that are kind of just like
short little bite-sized ones but then
there's really kind of there's three
really big movies that I want to get
into talking about and then I have a
couple more like that if we get to then
we get to them and if we don't we don't
because the two at the end like we've
already talked about a little bit like
in other formats so you know so there's
that
um and then Zach said you're gonna do
the 60s Cleopatra I thought about that
doing that one too but I don't know
that's the thing I feel like I wanted
ones like I said that almost seemed like
they were kind of cursed or they had
like all kind of like horrible injuries
and all kind of just terrible crazy [ __ ]
happening I feel like yes bad [ __ ]
happened in the back of Cleopatra but I
feel like that was mostly due to it
being like really really over budget and
like really you know what I mean because
wasn't it a thing where um Elizabeth
Taylor like she asked for so much money
that it was already like over budget
before they even [ __ ] started I don't
know or something like that you know
what I mean so I don't know like I said
so it was hard for me to narrow it down
so if I don't get to the one I mean this
is a topic that we will probably have to
revisit at some point
Pat Hatfield is talking about the
Conqueror that's one that I actually did
want to get into a little bit uh because
yeah that was [ __ ] horrifying so you
know but uh we might do Heaven's Gate uh
or Heaven's Gate like um yeah Heaven's
Gate like on the next one because that
was a cult Heaven's game right no no no
the the movie oh the movie the movie
I've never heard of it yeah yeah it was
oh it's a very very famous uh you know
kind of
Hollywood [ __ ] show that movie was
so that might be on a on a second one
you know what I mean
uh Richard Brown said wasn't Cecil B
Demille notorious for killing people
during his shoots yeah you would be
shocked at how many people like died on
movie sets back then because the thing
about it is that
particularly the actors I feel like the
crew members like you know people that
did lighting and stuff like that they
were actually kind of like unionized and
they had protections before actors did
so for a long time like actors just got
completely [ __ ] on
um and they would just make them do all
kind of [ __ ] and they didn't really have
any recourse uh you know what I mean so
which they we'll talk about that a
little bit when you talk about The
Wizard of Oz because well during the
time of the Silver Screen they were just
dive a dozen actors well yeah that's
what I'm saying they were disposable
that's what I'm saying so it's like they
didn't really care all that much like if
something bad happened to you and they
were just like oh well
you know you got to work like [ __ ] 24
hours most of them kind of came from the
dregs of society
most actors you know they didn't come
from money they had no pull and they
basically had to beg their way into a
job at the studio and then they just
treated them like dirt for a long time
then they eventually got unionized that
that's really
and some of them even if they became
Stars they treated them pretty badly
they did yeah yeah they did pretty bad
well when we were when we did the show
about uh Bella Lugosi and Boris Karloff
um Boris Karloff was actually one of the
first people that started
the whole he wasn't the only one but him
and um some other actors got together
and they were the ones that started like
the Screen Actors Guild and all that
kind of stuff so because he was tired of
well he got injured too like in uh doing
Frankenstein like I think it [ __ ] up
his back like forever because they
didn't really you know and and like I
said back then you know and we'll talk
about this when we talk about Wizard of
Oz too but it's just like you know the
makeup they have the costuming and [ __ ]
like that they didn't really care like
if the actors were uncomfortable or if
the makeup was toxic or anything like
that so you know if if something like
that happened they and you cried about
it they were just like
oh well you know nothing to do
Danny Rowling said a horror adult
version of Wizard of Oz would be sick
especially the Tin Man axing up a bunch
of wolves like in the story
um I'm surprised nobody's made that
somebody must have made that I mean it's
just ripe for I know they've done you
know
well didn't they do wicked isn't that
about isn't that about the Wicked Witch
of the West I don't think that's that's
not horror though it's like Return to Oz
had had a lot of yeah I gotta do I gotta
do that on my on my scare Salon channel
uh what if you if you saw it today I
posted a video about mad monster party
speaking of Boris Karloff but Return to
Oz is definitely one that uh yeah that I
want to do maybe I'll do it next week
starring an itty bitty farooza bulk yeah
cute little Fairuza book she's probably
about 12 maybe something like that maybe
yeah
that's yeah I remember that being I
haven't seen it a long time but I
remember it being like pretty scary I
remember liking it I liked it too but it
was like it was scary like a lot of
people said when they saw that as kids
it was like really traumatic you know
what I mean
um but yeah so yeah Pat Hatfield talking
about League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
causing Sean Connery to retire yeah
uh Pat says there's a horrific kind of
sequel to The Wizard of Oz coming out I
think it's called don't go back to Oz
there's a trailer on YouTube hmm well I
don't know
I mean like I said there's and there's
so many other books in the series too
that you could like totally do something
with that but
I don't know other than I think Wizard
of Oz and Return to Oz are the only odds
related things that I've seen
uh Zach says no time to die was kind of
a disaster yeah I remember that well see
that's the thing it's like you never
know though no time to die uh double o
seven yeah yeah okay I don't know if
there's more than one no okay
um that's the thing I kind of wanted to
because there are two different things
there's kind of like movies that were
[ __ ] shows behind the scene and then
they ended up you know like Ishtar or
something like that that came out and
everybody just like grapped on it
because it was terrible but then there's
movies that very famously were just like
a [ __ ] nightmare to film but then
they came out and they were fantastic so
you never really know how it's gonna end
up I remember seeing Ishtar as a kid
because it kept playing it on cable over
and over again probably trying to make
their money back somehow and uh I
remember being entertained but I was a
kid
I don't actually remember if I've ever
seen it or I've I think I've seen like
parts of it but I don't think I've ever
like sat there and watched the whole
thing yeah
I don't know if I'm curious enough to
sit there and watch the whole thing
though I mean I kind of am but let's
remember they're out in the desert a
bunch of horses
yeah when they're an English girl
hanging out with a bunch of like Arabian
guys or something uh it was it was like
some kind of romance and then there was
a
there's some was some kind of war going
on you know yeah that's I just remember
it's just kind of entertaining to watch
but I don't really remember much about
it I don't either yeah I mean
I think I remember I saw a couple scenes
from it and I was just kind of like
like it didn't seem like all that funny
or it seemed like a little try hard so I
kind of remember it being a little bit
like Romancing the Stone or something
he was trying to be something like that
yeah well that was kind of like the well
didn't Ishtar come out in like that was
80 what 87 something no or was it I
think it might have been more like 83 or
4 84 maybe I thought it was like later
80s like 87. yeah I gotta maybe have it
confused with something else but I could
be wrong too I don't really remember
but yeah that was I mean the 80s were
very big on kind of these like you know
exotic Adventure kind of kind of movies
because Indiana Jones and all that and
then like you had the kid version which
was like The Goonies and [ __ ] like that
um Daniel Rowling's talking about crawl
space almost got Klaus Kinski waxed by
the director yeah we reviewed crawl
space not too long ago however uh we are
going to be talking about uh Klaus
Kinski and Werner Herzog because we're
going to be talking about fitzgeraldo no
two totally unacceptable dudes
this guy well and like I said
fitzgeraldo is one of those movies that
is famously probably one of the most
famous like [ __ ] shows there's also a
documentary about the making of that
because it was again like a total
disaster but that movie actually came
out
like pretty great but that one that [ __ ]
was crazy and it wasn't all Klaus
kinsky's fault a lot of it was to be
fair but um some stuff just like crazy
[ __ ] happened like horrible injuries and
all this other kind of stuff uh John
Smith said anyone brought up the abyss
yet that was another one that I was
thinking about mentioning any time that
you're gonna film
underwater
um you know because I think I have a
little bit about Titanic and stuff like
that and uh and the abyss you're gonna
have a bad time uh because I think on
the abyss there were a couple and maybe
on Titanic as well they were like
uh you know people got underwater like
you know uh the bends and [ __ ] like that
and uh I think there was also
um [ __ ] what else was I gonna say oh and
I was gonna say too that remember when
we were talking about Jaws uh you know
Steven Spielberg who was very young at
the time he's like hey we're gonna film
this on the real ocean because you know
realism and uh then he was like oh maybe
that was a stupid idea but uh but they
did ask him like later on he said well I
would still do it because normally when
they shoot like you know a movie and
you're supposed to be out on the ocean
they would just film it like in a big
water tank or something like that they
don't usually shoot on the real ocean
for obvious reasons but um I guess he
kind of wanted it to uh look like the
real ocean so yeah so it in a way and
you know and we talked about Jaws too
like where the shark didn't work and all
that other kind of stuff but a lot of
the stuff that was kind of you know
shitty and like made the set really hard
like actually ended up working to the
movies benefit that doesn't always
happen that doesn't always happen but
sometimes when you get lucky and I think
too like the guy that paid that played
uh Quint Robert Shaw I think he was like
drunk all the time and he was like hard
to deal with so it was that as well I
mean that's good though but yeah that's
what I mean that was the best that
character was the best he was the best
part of the baby I know see but like see
sometimes well Dreyfus that doesn't yeah
sometimes that doesn't translate well to
screen sometimes conflict onset is good
like it you end up with a good movie but
sometimes like not so much not so much I
always like Dreyfus though
it was just kind of like the the short
ever the short guy every man kind of but
wasn't wasn't he wasn't a beta though
you know what I'm talking about he he
would [ __ ] he would man up I liked it
I liked that character that you know
well I say him character he played those
characters a lot yeah like uh yeah that
was his Niche that was his day right he
was kind of the every man kind of
Underdog but he [ __ ] Rose to the
occasion that was that was his job now
he he went out to go [ __ ] see the
aliens and then he went out to go see
the [ __ ] shark he went out and I did
all that [ __ ] that's what Dreyfus did he
was right for adventure yeah he would
just go up and like deal with all that
[ __ ] yeah he left with the aliens
he lost his wife said [ __ ] it I'm going
with the aliens it's like you and your
goes up you and your mashed potato
mountains yeah
making a mountain in his living room
that's a [ __ ] excellent movie
I know we did yeah we did uh we did a
review of that a while back too
yeah Mega saying like James Cameron
almost killed them all yeah pretty much
I mean
directors will go a long way for a very
similitude I guess they're like you know
nowadays like I said they have
protections but
that air is over
yeah that whole thing that's true all
those I mean [ __ ] still happens nowadays
because when I was looking for once
because I was kind of more interested
more like kind of classic movies and
stuff but there's still like bad [ __ ]
happens on sets nowadays obviously
because they got all that [ __ ] dad with
science and they're using all this
[ __ ]
technology and you know
sets that are 3D but it's all [ __ ] HD
uh screens so you can make anybody look
like they're anywhere now that's how
they're doing all the Star Wars [ __ ] so
it's just not it's not what it was
and um
it's kind of stale the writing's bad uh
evidently they're [ __ ] they took a
huge hit like 140 billion dollars last
year is [ __ ] what Hollywood is all
what the Hollywood Studios all together
lost in in the market share they just
they just suck they're gonna have to
[ __ ] Revitalize it and it revitalized
itself several times you know Spielberg
and Lucas and all those guys they didn't
come from the studios they were into
Indie filmmakers that got picked up by
Studios
they really helped rebuild Hollywood
from
in the early 80s late 70s
if it wasn't for them it would have just
been [ __ ] stale-ass westerns and cop
flicks forever because that's that's
what Hollywood did
but it's come back around again they're
just not much art there anymore you know
it I think it'll fix itself there's good
Indie stuff going on going on out there
if it had Studio backing
you could probably make some interesting
movies again
well and the thing about it is that I
think there's lots of interesting movies
out there it's just that just like
almost always they're usually Indie
movies or they're smaller movies and you
know
there's all kind of good [ __ ] out there
even Disney the nightmare Disney is a
nightmare of a [ __ ] company all right
it had a winner on its hands Mandalorian
and then they stepped on their own dick
and then they [ __ ] up by a bunch of
other [ __ ] because they
they don't know how they don't know how
to [ __ ] make art you know John fravoe
did they should have put him in charge
of everything all that [ __ ] it had been
like the MCU he better but
you just can't have too too many too
many [ __ ] Cooks in the kitchen
it's just you know
you have to have [ __ ] Senior
Management and be able to fire people
yeah John Smith is talking about the
documentary about the 90s island of Dr
Moreau yeah that was on I don't know if
it's on shutter anymore but it was on
shutter for a while don't [ __ ] what
anybody says I like that movie
yeah well well they're they're not
talking about like what the quality of
the movie is they're talking about all
the crazy [ __ ] that went on behind the
scenes but it flopped it did we flopped
well I've seen I remember seeing it I
don't even remember like thinking one
way or the other about it but now that
I'm like looking at stills from it and
everything like that it looks ridiculous
so now it's so now I kind of have to
like re-watch it because I want to see
what it was by the standards of its day
it was just kind of mediocre it was just
something kind of in the middle
standards were higher back then
um
but today if that come out today I think
people probably would have would have
enjoyed it you know maybe I don't know I
haven't seen it so I can't really judge
it was okay
dude was making these down by you know
uh animal human hybrids out on a on an
island I mean that's not the first time
that that's been adapted that's in H.G
Wells yeah sorry they made it back in
the [ __ ] I think bird eye Gordon
produced one back in the [ __ ] 70s
and I was like because remember over on
my scarce Salon Channel I did like a
double like a Creature Feature bird eye
Gordon Creature Feature with like um
Empire the ants and food the gods and
then the third one that they did was
you know was uh island of Dr morale but
and I was like oh I should have done a
triple feature but you know I didn't get
around Marlon Brando was in it being
crazy as [ __ ] he was just being crazy as
[ __ ] to the whole thing which is great
like I said the [ __ ] The Stills he is
are hilarious yeah he had a his face was
all painted white they had that funny
like sun hat on yeah son had had an
umbrella on the top of it I think didn't
have an umbrella on top of it or
something he was just a wacko you know
and he was afraid yeah a little bit a
little bit
afraid of ultraviolet radiation
I mean okay but Marlon Brandon was crazy
yeah
I mean a lot of actors are crazy you
kind of have to be a little bit crazy I
mean it's actually I'm more surprised
when that most of them are relatively
normal yeah because I would think I mean
if it was my job to like have to go in
to like play other people all the time I
think that would probably drive me crazy
after a while so you'd be talking
tomorrow on the brand though and [ __ ]
if you the longer you talk to him the
higher the chances where he was gonna
try to kiss you that's that's what he
was known for
as long as he doesn't like try to try to
try to stick a stick of butter up my
butt then you know I mean no no no no he
was just trying you didn't see that
before
you just try to [ __ ] and he'd kiss man
you know
oh that's okay yeah he's just he's a
weird dude babe
Richard Brown said the salon episodes
are fantastic Jenny thank you very much
yeah I I am having a good time with
those I'm doing like some retro [ __ ] you
know what I mean I think this weekend
sometime I'll put up the next six
episodes of Thriller the forest Car Lot
show if I have time to watch them but so
we're doing a Boris Karloff week because
I did bad monster party today because he
was going to
and uh yeah they're talking about the
crow which like I said yeah that was
kind of like a big one too but we
already reviewed that and honestly I
don't think I mean other I mean
obviously that's like terrible that
Brandon Lee got killed and everything
like that but I don't think other than
that I don't think that it was like any
worse
than normal like I think that was the
only thing that happened on that
um grandpar says excellent documentary
about the making of Apocalypse Now
called hearts of Darkness about how
Martin Sheen and Francis Ford Coppola
went nuts during filming uh Brando
helped them get to that point yeah when
we were talking about Apocalypse Now we
see because I think Martin Sheen had a
heart attack on the set of that too
didn't he like when he was young like
yeah it was supposedly like really
really terrible
um let's see John Smith said fur is a
Bach wait a minute I lost it oh acquired
that thing that's death for
a Hollywood actress being called
difficult she just didn't want to be
involved in that Madness anymore
that's euphemism for not wanting to put
out too well yeah that's what I mean
what does difficult mean what is
difficult like what she doesn't she's
too difficult she wouldn't do what I
said yeah she wouldn't give me the ass
oh
let's see
and let's see
yeah Danny Rowling said the island of Dr
Morrow is my favorite Kilmer film
alongside Wonderland
now see I'm now I'm gonna have to like
re-watch it I liked it I haven't seen it
in a long time kind of reminded me of
the howling in a certain way had a lot
of like half human wear type people
um I liked it I thought it was good you
know in the howling they had the damn
um werewolf Colony out in the woods and
there was a anthropologist that was uh
or a sociologist that was studying them
and
kind of like a scientist was in charge
of them watching it all happen that kind
of reminded me of the island of Dr
Moreau yeah yeah where you have this
doctor but he's not he's he's making
them he's making these Animal Human
hybrids and farooza was it was one of
them she was like his daughter
she looked human but she was turning
into a cat slowly turning into a catchy
Park cat
I wish he was doing it he's trying to
come up for like uh
cures for diseases because animals
didn't get certain diseases he was just
blending people and animal together to
make them more resistant to disease or
just because it would be cool I wouldn't
mind having well he was crazy some fins
or wings or something like that he's the
obvious mad man
well yeah somebody pointed out too that
I think the first film version of island
of Dr Moreau had Charles Lawton in it
who was also in the old dark house which
we just talked about yesterday
so there was all right so um in the show
sorry to piss you all off we're gonna
run some commercials uh it's the
holidays and [ __ ]
we're in a [ __ ] nut roll because uh
you know all these [ __ ] expenses
hitting us at once and over the years
Jenny and I haven't noticed that we've
lost so many subscribers we went down
from getting well patreon
subscribers still going up yes
subscribers go up patrons going down
we used to get 600 a month from
patronage now it's only 300. and it was
like that for about a year and a half
they really didn't matter up until
recently now that's enough to make a
difference so we got to actually start
working and that [ __ ] suck we got to
start I've been working the whole time
we gotta start working
we got to start advertising and plugging
got to start advertising and plugging
Jenny's books her other channels uh got
to start asking for patrons so we're
gonna start handing out the collection
plate and we've uh gonna have Jenny's
got some new commercials type [ __ ] that
she's gonna make and after the New Year
the show is going to be um updated with
intros and outros and stuff so
like I said I might kind of streamline
it a little bit too like maybe I mean
I'm still going to put up a lot of
videos but I might like cut out a couple
like I might just do like a couple movie
reviews a week and
um you know just like maybe one scarce
line and one crime immemorial because
I'm trying to do like too many and I
think I'm getting like behind you know
what I mean on other stuff and
the return on make on this show actually
is kind of takes time compared to the
the other income streams that we have
going like Jenny's graphic design
company and everything
that's
that's actually competing for time with
this
so
we're leopards and leopards really don't
want to change their spots we just want
to become better leopards if you know
what I'm talking about so we can't start
um asking for money e-begging ain't that
some [ __ ] that's just not eBay it's just
it's just advertising we it's been so
long since we've advertised and plugged
and that's also affected um incomes I
just keep forgetting because like I said
since since we went to so many live
streams like I feel like we just always
are having a good time and we're talking
to you guys and I just like kind of just
forget to do it you know what I mean
grandpa said yeah quality is always more
important than quantity that's kind of
what I was getting into I was thinking
to myself
um you know I like doing all of the um
you know movie reviews and all the stuff
that I do every week but I was getting
to a point where I was just like I was
like I feel like I'm rushing through
everything and I feel like I could do
them a lot better if I did like a couple
fewer like every week so I might start
doing that like in the new year you know
what I mean because I have gotten a
little bit behind like like for example
this week I haven't even put up a book
review if you didn't notice because I
started reading the book but and it's
good but I just haven't had time to
finish it and like you know do a review
of it yeah so another thing we'll start
plugging
is that some people are not set up to
give super chats and then some people
are listening to the show but not live
they're listening to record recorded so
we're going to start plugging Jenny's uh
cash app
that way you can send money directly to
Jenny to Jenny through her cash app but
they have to worry about super chats or
PayPal or PayPal or any other [ __ ] if
you guys have cash app
and we may be able to do damn what's the
other one the one that's on the bank
card
um what Zell Zell maybe we could do Zell
too we'll plug both of those
yeah because I have a couple clients
that pay me through something right just
go right into my which can go right into
our bank account which I mean anyways
we'll make some commercials for that
and we'll keep plugging your cash app
and your Zell
I have to say though that we could
probably put that in the description box
actually
yeah your cash out I mean yeah I mean my
PayPal is in there and our patreon link
is in there like all this stuff is most
of the stuff is in the uh and also last
week I finally remembered to put the
link to my scare Salon Channel and my
crime Memorial Channel I put that in the
description box because I don't know why
I didn't think of that before but uh
yeah Dave says venmo too yeah there you
go I think do I fanbo
yeah probably I have like I pretty much
like all the apps on my phone because
like I said I have like different
clients and everybody prefers to use a
different thing so
so I have like all the apps like on my
phone because different people want to
pay in different ways and that's fine
with me whatever so you're gonna have to
um bear with us we're gonna be doing
plugging and advertising but everybody
else does it and uh also Channel's been
monetized the the channels that are
monetized we have a different selection
so we can get the commercials that'll be
in the middle of the show now won't they
yeah I just start putting them like bed
rolls because you get like a little bit
more more money right because before I
didn't do it before because like I don't
I don't really like watching stuff with
mid-rolls in it but then I was like well
you do get more money from that right
yeah and then just like skipping up at
the beginning right and any even a small
Improvement would make a big difference
for us
yeah we're at the point where two or
three hundred dollars a month makes a
difference now
so
well what I was going to say is that
um we had we did get a new Patron named
Stephanie okay so thank you very much
Stephanie
and also I wanted to thank Dermot who's
been our fan for like um who's been on
here for like a really long time and he
actually increased his patreon support
and he also like sent me extra money on
PayPal appreciate it thank you so I
appreciate that very much um I might
have mentioned it before but I just like
to do it on there's Super Chat thank you
thank you thank you grandthers we all
got to make a nickel and a dollar yeah I
mean seriously like I said and I feel
bad because it's just kind of like
you know I like to just chill out and do
the show but but we forget we have all
these different streams
um patronage we get that once a month
and I think that's timely super chats
take 60 days for us to get that super
chat I think in it well it's what they
do yeah the super chats and the ad
Revenue yeah from YouTube are all one
thing okay it comes over your Google
AdSense account okay so um but you'll
usually get it like the month after
right so um like on the 21st 30 to 60
days something like that like so so if
somebody sent like for example if
somebody sent a Super Chat in December
then I would get it January 20 January
21st right you know what I mean yeah but
then we have other ways we can get it
like I said uh you know cash app and
sell once those are set up you'll be
able to get we'll get that the same day
it means it's instant
and uh YouTube doesn't doesn't get
anything
yeah so it's good
but like I said that's what it's it's
not just whatever's most like YouTube
It's it goes through Google AdSense is
what it does you have to have a Google
AdSense account and they all the super
chats and all the revenue that you get
from people clicking on your ads
um that's all love lumped into one thing
and they'll just send you one big lump
sum Tammy's asking to plug Tom's only
fans yeah
I haven't started the only fans yet
[Laughter]
I know everybody liked keeps us all the
talents to do that
I don't think I don't think you can make
any money on that [ __ ] anymore can you
uh probably not
I mean unless you have like a really
weird Niche or something yeah
Danny says Tom's head could be Jenny's
crystal ball for the Oz part of the show
I like the wicked witch Hobbies will
make them sleep
man I haven't seen the wizard of oz in a
long time
yeah it was all kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
going on behind the scenes of that I was
thinking the other day that
um Wizard of Oz
so I'll kind of mentioned this in a bit
but like the all the actors the little
people that played the munchkins they
said those [ __ ] were wild they
made a whole movie about it did you see
it Carrie Fisher was in it was called
under the rainbow yeah Chevy Chase was
in it too they used to play it on cable
all the time I probably saw it like a
million times like back in the old days
and it was about
because they were like the the little
people Wranglers like for The Wizard of
Oz movie so it was set like back in the
30s and like all the crazy [ __ ] that
they got up to like you know it was a
funny movie but looking at it now it's
like probably wasn't all that funny like
the [ __ ] they were doing but you know
we'll get into that in a little bit so
you know man I'm out of ice already so
where are you yeah I got some more made
I mean I don't feel too bad we've been
going almost 40 minutes it's almost 40
minutes
but yeah so I don't know like I said I
had to like real quick because like I
said I'm kind of behind on stuff but I
did like pop a couple if you've been
watching my scare Salon
um videos I have been like popping
little
commercials in those usually just one
like at the end or whatever like for
whatever like my books or my games or
whatever it is but I so I got a bunch of
those but and I still have a bunch of
I saw a bunch of games I don't have
commercials for because I just don't
have time to make them
you know what I mean
the Pearl is in the room oh my God I had
forgotten all about that
man now I want to watch that movie again
I haven't seen I haven't seen that movie
in such a long time that was one of
those movies that was just on constantly
I think I saw that movie like at least
400 times when I was growing up yeah
all right go ahead
uh John Smith said from what I
understand the munchkin stories were
mainly started by Judy Garland's uh
drunken drug addictive rants on chat
shows not really based on truth yeah I'm
yeah I don't know I mean I wonder like
it was kind of getting around but I
don't really know
I don't really know like how much of it
was true or not I feel so bad for poor
Judy Garland what
okay
what's the matter
okay
Pokey just walks in the room and she's
like I was like okay
um Dave says I think it's on Prime
see
I remember that movie being really funny
but I haven't seen it in a long time
what is it it's like is it late 70s or
early 80s I thought it was 82 but maybe
it's older than that
it was that I remember that being gone
all the time and I remember that movie
Foul Play being on all the time
that also had Chevy Chase in it and had
Goldie Hawn and Burgess Meredith and I
remember liking that one because it was
like a murder mystery but it was also
like a comedy
man those are like two more movies that
I'm gonna have to like review at some
point yeah Dave said early 80s that's
what I thought I thought it was like 81
or 82 or something like that
yeah John Smith said sad to say but Judy
is not what she would describe as a
reliable eyewitness yeah like I said I
feel so bad for her because I mean we'll
get into that a little bit too we can
talk about Wizard of Oz but like that
girl like didn't really have a chance to
be honest with you but she started out
when she was young and they're like hey
take all these drugs and you know we all
know how that turned out
she was younger than me when she died
isn't that crazy
yeah 47 years old she died
slasher Fred said speaking of The Wizard
of Oz
it was a mini-series in the 2000s called
tin man which is sort of a modern
version of The Wizard of Oz
um I never heard of that actually
Dave says and Billy Barty was in Foul
Play Too the Bible salesman yeah I
forgot about that
holy [ __ ]
man you remember that movie like really
good I really really do have to like
[ __ ] watch that again I remember that
being really funny we should do a double
feature one time like under the rainbow
and foul play
80s 80s cable Classics because they
played that [ __ ] all the time because
we've already talked about the other
movie that I saw a million times was
time after time which was amazing and
we've already talked about that but then
the other two movies that I used to see
all the time on cable back then were
Grease 2 which actually which I actually
like fight me you know I know it's not
as good as the first degree it's okay
but it's it wasn't terrible I thought it
was pretty good
um I thought like Michelle Pfeiffer was
cute in it
um and also the pirate movie which
was not good uh I remember that one yeah
it was the Pirates of Penzance but it
was like um a modernized version like
Chrissy McNichol was in it and like the
dude from the Blue Lagoon or whatever
what's that dude's name Christopher
Atkins
yeah
but I I remember when I first saw it I
didn't realize that it was like another
version of The Pirates of Penzance until
we saw the Pirates of Penzance like in
my chorus class like we saw the one with
um with what's his face in it uh the guy
that was in Fish Called Wanda what's
that dude's name God damn it I'll think
of it in like five seconds
probably
John Smith said I prefer the songs in
Greece too yeah I said it okay so I'm
not the only one I don't know if I
prefer the song I did when I was a kid
but I mean the older I've gotten I think
I like the songs from Grease one better
but honestly like I will defend Greece
too I think it's a good movie and I
think the songs are good
I mean I really like
um I like that charade song I like the
um the one they do at the end with the
the seasons like that goes into like the
sad song when she thinks the dude's dead
and all that kind of stuff that's like a
good song and the reproduction that's a
funny song
that's a good I used to have the vinyl
like soundtrack I don't know what
happened to it but I used to have it
when I was a kid Kevin Klein thank you
that's his name Kevin Klein he was in
the version of Pirates of Penzance that
I saw
yeah Dave said uh Greece too I know the
words to every song I do as well I do as
well yeah I used to have the I used to
have the record
I don't know where it is now but uh
Greece was a big hit so they were just
like oh you want more of that and they
just kind of made another one yeah they
just made another one and like I said
Michelle Pfeiffer was in it yeah
and she was good I liked her I liked her
character I thought she was cute as [ __ ]
Adrian's Abed was in that [ __ ]
um it was barely a sequel it was just
another one yeah I mean it was just like
the next year Frenchie was in it yeah
yeah she was she was like the and some
of the teachers yeah were like came back
but I mean mostly it was like different
characters but that's okay I mean
because the ones from the first one they
graduated yeah and the song was the
songs were all right
and they went to motorcycles instead of
cars yeah so you know
yeah
because that first one though
yeah that first one was [ __ ] awesome
I know and uh yeah you know
me and Jenny watch Grease we even got
the live TV live version is good too
that was fantastic yeah so I was really
surprised I like how good that was they
streamed it live on television and it
like like a play and it was good they
were running around and going from
Studio yeah it was live live it was good
real good we've watched it a couple
times since then
they had a bunch of like guest rock
stars doing songs Bell Biv DeVoe was on
there from back in the 90s they were on
there doing Beauty School Dropout number
one in the charts yeah yeah Bell Biv
DeVoe yeah
where are my Kids in the Hall of fans at
that's what that was bro
you never saw kid in the hall they had a
whole sketch about them and every time I
hear that like I always think of that
[ __ ] kids of the hall sketch
um let's see Zach says I especially feel
bad for directors who make a super
acclaimed movie than follow it with a
bomb and their career kind of Tanks
after that I can't imagine being in that
headspace and honestly that seems to
happen quite a bit
you know
I don't know if it's just because like
some directors they make like some
amazing thing and it's like some passion
project and they wanted to make it for
like a really long time and then they
make it and everybody's like oh my God
it's the most amazing thing ever and
then like for their next follow-up like
nothing is gonna live up to that so it's
just like whatever they make everyone's
just kind of like ah we're kind of over
you bye you know what I mean
it seems like it's that seems to happen
more than the reverse like guys that
just like make better and better movies
like every single time
you know you talk about directors yeah
directors have a shelf life well yeah
even good directors are gone after about
four or five movies six movies they're
lucky not always like I said but
Spielberg was he he was kind of an
exception he had a bunch of good ones
but even his kind of got a little stale
um
James Cameron uh
he went steel pretty quick they're just
they just get played out you know what I
mean it's like singers you know they had
Morrissey on there saying you know
talking about how old he is now and he's
still able to sing and he's like he felt
like he's lucky because there's the guys
who were famous and and when they were
20 but now they just can't write songs
like they used to you know because the
magic's gone you know a lot of has to do
with
being young and being hungry for it and
well you have to have a passion for it
you have to really want to do that yeah
and there's uh something about
being slightly new to everything
gives you a certain
ability to make Mystique happen where
there really isn't any to to a mature
person you know what I mean if I can um
but you can re-experience it through
storytelling you know and
a story told by a 25 year old it seems
to be more compelling than one that's
told by a 55 year old well it depends
what the story is about you know what I
mean I'll go that far right well and I
think too like you said I think you kind
of like sort of alluded to this but I
think it's good to kind of stay on top
of you don't necessarily have to stay on
top of new technology but you I think
you should be like challenging yourself
all the time you know I mean sometimes
that has to do because you know it's
very very easy for someone who gets
older to be like oh I don't know about
all this newfangled you know what's this
or whatever these youths today but if
you kind of go out there and say oh I'm
really interested in this new technology
or this new technique or this new
something and you kind of challenge
yourself to make something in that
regard like and I think that that will
kind of like Revitalize your creative
juices because you're you're exploring
territory that's new to you and so it
kind of like like I said it kind of like
maybe reinvigorates like your passion
for the medium and things like that
I think it's I'm thinking of like you
know like when David Lynch kind of got
into
um digital like when when it was a new
thing like that everybody was like
shooting movies on digital like back in
those days and he like just got right in
there with that and started shooting all
his [ __ ] on digital and he's like well
[ __ ] I'm gonna do this because I can
control you know everything about the
movie that I would I can and he got
really into that so I think that's it's
it's good like not to get stale you
always have to like look for new things
to be doing well it's also the genre too
these are movies right okay
we have to we have to ask ourselves what
is a movie a movie is
an old medium you know the silent era
the silent era was the early 1900s was a
long time ago man okay
and um
it's slowly being replaced with things
like series like Netflix series type
stuff and video games
eventually things like movies will kind
of be seen kind of like as it
be put on the same
be putting the same [ __ ]
genres maybe like epic poetry like
nobody's breeding Beowulf anymore you
know reading uh except in school yeah
except in school you know it's cool you
know a self-contained story that lasts
you know an hour and a half maybe two
hours and then you had this visual
experience that's gone well back in the
day a visual experience an audio visual
experience was a big deal on film now
everybody children are growing up with
these little things we're constantly
bombarded with audio visual experiences
mixed with
[ __ ] information and
they don't experience things the way we
do yeah I mean like it was a big deal to
see a music video when we were kids
because you didn't choose when it was
going to happen you had to be sitting in
front of a [ __ ] tube and you had to
wait for them to play it and you'd
probably never see it again
man I saw a Bauhaus video you did yeah
oh yeah then later on you know if you
could buy the VHS in the and the VHS
tape might be 60 70 that was a lot of
money back then
you try to Bootleg it
it wasn't until the 90s you know people
were bootlegging VHS stuff but in the
80s
you didn't have control over the medium
like you did today now I was the Press
of a button you can see and hear
anything so people are kind of spoiled
movies aren't really where it's at
video games are a lot more compelling
you know like uh
I love the Fallout series they're gonna
make a mini series about Fallout
so I'm actually shocked it took them
this long yeah
I like the merchandising from that
property you can buy posters and little
statues that are represent things that
were well I like anything well that's
kind of what I thought was so cool about
that is they have a real commitment to
the theming and I like that they just
have this whole I mean they made a whole
entire universe yeah with all of these
little things in it and all of this kind
of like multimedia I think that's like
really really cool one of the girls from
Club she died of cancer another one that
died of cancer what was her name again
one that was worked at the uh she was a
waitress for a while yeah yeah what was
her name do you remember
she wasn't a good friend of ours but we
used to see her every now and then
um
um [ __ ] what was her name
she died I guess about a year ago two
years ago something like that she was
way into
um she was she was young
died a damn
internal cancer I think was kind of like
ovarian cancer or something just ate her
up
um
she actually had she loved Fallout
goth check she when she wasn't in the
club walking around Amber that's right
poor Amber
when uh when she was just uh walking
around during the daytime she wore
vault-tec clothes she had vault-tech
stuff
they actually had branded clothes yeah
which that's [ __ ] genius
well yeah like I said you can completely
immerse yourself in this entire world
yeah and just
I don't know I just think that's pretty
awesome that it's like they have this
whole team of people and they just come
up with this whole entire universe and
they make everything in it yeah and
that's like that's so cool to me yeah
and the amount of money that that
generates over time because you're not
dependent on a theater
people have it in their computer and
they're playing it and they play it for
years and years and new people joined in
so a market for a secondary market for
products that are related to that
Universe are emerges and they'll
actually have you know
Fallout branded stuff yeah I mean and
that's just an extension of what they
started doing in you know with movies
obviously but movies were the Prototype
Star Wars right toy merchandising yeah
you know and I mean they had done it
kind of like half-assed before then
because they did a Star Trek and all
that kind of stuff but it was never any
good I think yeah I think like Star Wars
was kind of like when the big oh my God
we can sell like all these toys like all
this merchandise that has to do with the
movie and that was like where everybody
jumped on that bandwagon well and like I
said during the 80s like [ __ ] man even
though all the cartoons that were on
during the 80s were all like basically
at half hour long commercials for yeah
toys like they thought of the toy line
first and they're like make make a make
a cartoon that like with these
characters in it so we could sell the
toys well the Fallout is like a movie
and it's a series of movies everything
you do in the game is like a movie
there's a story and you're involved and
you're controlling it you're doing stuff
and it's all these little movies that
you're watching basically and you're
interacting with it inside this video
game it it's like a virtual world you
know the mission based stuff kind of
like moral wind you know
but a lot better
you know which goes back to like
Wizardry back on the Apple 2E you know
if I could boy times have changed
and uh you could probably put that game
in a watch now but that's how little
data that that game evolved but
um yeah
the future is those video games and
they're going to be like in a metaverse
no movie will be able to compete with it
but I think movies will still exist yeah
um I mean it's it's an art for like you
know what I mean it's like people still
do paintings right and sculptures they
still write novels it just won't be as
dominant there won't be as they're right
because there's other choices but like I
don't think they're going anywhere
because the thing about movies that that
people like is you know they kind of
incorporate a lot of different artistic
things in one thing it's like it's
visuals it's music it's you know it's a
story it's it's all this other kind of
stuff going on and like I said you know
video games are like the next iteration
of that because you can actually immerse
yourself into the story and like play it
the way you want to play it but I don't
like I said because novels haven't gone
anywhere
um you know paintings haven't gone
anywhere so I don't think poetry is gone
well it's not gone but it's like it's
not songs now not that many people right
but yeah I would argue that like yeah
music is a form of poetry so I don't
really like thinking about it but it is
gone um but for Hollywood I'm just
pointing at Hollywood for Hollywood and
Disney to survive they've got to listen
to the customer they've got to change
their ways they've got to be making
things that make [ __ ] money and they
just lose money now
um which they need you know making a
[ __ ] Fallout series I don't know
who's going to carry it if it's done
well that would be badass
I'd like to see it
I'd be interested to see it I don't know
I think you could really [ __ ] that up
you could really [ __ ] well that's what I
was thinking that's what I was thinking
done right because it's like I mean I
don't know look how they [ __ ] up blood
rain
[Laughter]
well yeah I mean that's the thing is I
kind of feel like any time you're taking
something and there's exceptions of
course but anytime you're taking
something that was like already a video
game a beloved video game yeah and
you're kind of taking it back a step and
making it into a movie or a series
that's like a really hard road to hoe
you know what I mean because it's just
kind of like people have already
experienced it
like immersively yeah and now you're
kind of like you're almost kind of like
freezing it into like oh we're making a
movie in this universe that you like but
you can't control that universe that you
like like you're used to yeah so I think
that's maybe why movies based on video
games usually don't turn out that good
that's there are exceptions to that of
course but I feel like maybe I thought
the Laura Crawford uh movies were okay
yeah but they were just okay they worked
out great well I mean I would rather
watch you play the video game than watch
the movies to be honest and you know
[ __ ] um
the best thing about it was oh what's
her name the actress what's uh [ __ ] Brad
Pitts [ __ ] Angelina Jolie Angelina
Jolie did a pretty good job in them
her and her her and her boobs
but you know
and uh the Practical effects mostly
is all right
you know it was what was it late 90s
when those movies came out I haven't I
don't remember yeah yeah John Smith said
blood rain was made by uh
Bowl yeah yeah that guy that like wants
to like box people that [ __ ] on his
movies yeah well he was kind of known
for that like he's known for making
video game adaptations that are terrible
so
you know I think that was just him
mostly
I mean I think probably you have a
better chance nowadays because I kind of
feel like for a long time you know they
started wanting to like in the 90s
they're like oh we should make you know
a video game based on this video game
property but they didn't really like
take the video games all that seriously
or like think of the lore behind the
game or anything like that the way they
would nowadays because nowadays I kind
of feel like you know most video games
are kind of more like a movie anyway so
it's kind of easier yeah to make it into
like a movie or a series property
whereas back then they were just kind of
like I don't know is there like there's
Mario and Luigi and it's like there's
mushrooms and it's like let's write a
story about that it's like it doesn't
have to make any sense they won't give a
[ __ ] you know what I mean like they
didn't really care yeah so
because it was a one-time thing or the
built-in audience they just put it out
there they go see the movie they don't
like it but you get your money that's
all
you know there were some cartoon based
movies that came out that bombed that I
liked um like the Speed Racer movie I
actually liked it I thought that was
pretty cool I thought his visuals were
right wait the animated one or the or
the live action one it was live action
with CG it was crazy as hell
I don't I remember seeing the trailers
for it but we didn't go see it I don't
think yeah we didn't go it's crazy as
hell okay yeah it looked good though but
it was just like it was I'd like to see
it on acid
it'd be even better on acid yeah okay
super super visual fair enough yeah
it wasn't something you took seriously
right it's like an anime you know
slasher friends in a Donkey Kong movie
would probably be terrible I was just
thinking I was thinking did anybody make
a Pac-Man movie
[Laughter]
I look look I'm an eternal optimist I
was like and you can make a good movie
out of anything but you have to know
what you're doing I think they did
Mortal Kombat that that one had a lot of
fans they did yeah they did Mortal
Kombat I don't think they did Street
Fighter now maybe they probably did yeah
they did they did they okay yeah I'm
pretty sure they made a Street Fighter
movie well see those kind of yeah I
think they did yeah I mean yeah like
those those kind of games are probably
like easier to translate because you
could at least do you know you got like
you got your heroes and villains and you
can kind of have like a whole thing it's
like this gang and this factions
fighting against this faction and [ __ ]
like that so it's like you kind of have
a ready-made conflict there but if you
have something like you know like I said
like Pac-Man or Burger time or yeah so
they like that burger burger
yeah now I kind of want to see that that
Burger Time the movie
uh yeah John Smith said there was a
Pac-Man cartoon when I was a kid yeah I
remember that I remember that there was
a Pac-Man cartoon
but it's like I wonder
I don't even remember what happened in
it I remember like seeing a couple of uh
a couple of um episodes of it but
he did it yeah he was like a character
like he had feet and like arms and stuff
but I don't remember what it was was he
in high school I don't even remember
I don't remember
but you know
John Smith said I tried watching Speed
Racer on LSD I gave up after 10 minutes
[Laughter]
visually I remembered liking it it was
just these weird candy colored [ __ ]
pastel colors and all this swirling
stuff and the cars the Mach 5 and
pops made a new Mach 5 or the first car
got wiped out that had then he came up
with a Mach 5 and you had uh what's her
name in the helicopter
um wasn't it um
uh the girl who played Wednesday Adams
what was her name um
hey Christina yeah the Christina Ricci
was running around flying a helicopter
and I think she played I think she
played Trixie or something if I remember
correctly I don't know it's been a long
time since I've seen it I didn't see it
yeah
yeah he said it hurt my eyes and my
brain I thought I'd been watching for
hours it was only 10 minutes
yeah it's jumping all over the place
it's like an acid trip see I don't know
if I like that though yeah it would
probably just like give me a migraine
looks like you mixed LSD and Coca-Cola
and Coke you're like what I think the
thing was uh Seattle like it was all
over the place I don't like that
just like settle down
and it's not just because I'm old it's
well maybe it is because I'm old but I
can't really like watch that kind of
it's probably you could probably see it
for free we'll I'll show it to you
I remember because I remember when we
were going to the theater like I
remember seeing the trailer yeah and I
was like man I don't think I really have
any interest in seeing that but I didn't
like the cartoon back in the day it's a
movie that's trying to be as frenetic as
a [ __ ] Japanese anime it's just you
know how you know how the edit yeah
Japanese anime is kind of insane it's
like that
and I'm just kind of like amazing
I don't really I don't need that in my
life
you know what I mean I used to love that
cartoon I was a kid Speed Racer I know
like I don't know I didn't like it like
my brother kind of liked it but I was
just kind of like I couldn't get into it
and then right next to it in California
I think right before it they had another
Japanese cartoon that they turned into
they Americanized it they called it
giant robot giant Robo or giant robot I
think is what it's called no
no no it was called Gigantor that's what
it was called
Gigantor I remember that gigantoro in
Japan was called tetsujin 28 28 I think
Tesson 28. and he was just this big
barrel chested [ __ ] robot and a kid
kid would control it with a joystick on
remote control back in the 30s it
started off black and white look at this
from the 30s and the 40s it was it was
pretty good the Japanese were into the
robots [ __ ] even before the war
I think it was 30s or 40s maybe I think
somebody might color it correctly it
could have been 60s I don't know
but it seemed to be old like an old
Mickey Mouse cartoon
okay that's kind of cool tetsujin 28 I
think it was what it was called
here they called it [ __ ] Gigantor
John Smith said yeah I had taken two
tabs the trip lasted 18 hours yeah yeah
they last a long time uh and was a bit
much later that night I watched Noah and
was terrified oh yeah I could see that
yeah I don't think I would like to watch
that on Ellis that might be a little bit
uh upsetting El Shaddai gonna come
[ __ ] punish you
Mr 88 said pixels is a live action uh
all about vintage video games yeah I
keep like hearing about that but I never
did watch it it has an awesome Pac-Man
sequence and is a fun watch yeah I heard
it was like pretty fun uh somebody like
Camp Guy saying I'm surprised they
haven't made a real good story about the
life of Ed Gein
um they did in 2001 starring Steve rails
back called gean actually there was one
from the 70s called deranged which was
which we reviewed it not too long ago
um and that one was actually really good
it wasn't
real like based in reality but it was
very Loosely based on Ed gain and I
actually really liked it much better
than I was expecting to
yeah oh Pat just brought that up yeah
deranged it's pretty good like like I
said it's not his name isn't Ed gain but
that's clearly who they're talking about
you know what I mean
uh Zach said I once watched Skyfall
while really really stoned and I
couldn't stop crying when Judy Dench
died
[Laughter]
I get it I get it yeah Zach's a fellow
[ __ ] James Bond [ __ ] lover man I
love James Bond too man it's like a
Daniel Daniel Craig's bond is my
favorite Bond
um I would say next to him I liked um
I liked um uh [ __ ]
the one from Living Daylights but I
didn't like the second one what was that
guy's name uh was that Timothy Dalton
Timothy Dalton yeah Timothy Dalton
because he was only in two he was only
in two and I only liked the first one
the second one was a little I mean he
was good Bob didn't it but the the story
is a little weak
the the first Timothy Dalton [ __ ] was
almost kind of like uh almost kind of
like a Daniel Craig movie I liked it a
perfect Bond movie I mean they were
trying to go more gritty back then but I
mean 90s gritty isn't the same as like
now he's gritty and people people
complained about the grittiness so they
brought back kind of the [ __ ] Roger
Moore kind of cheese yeah for the second
one I mean it was still good
but uh uh but it wasn't that good you
know
I mean they were parachuting into the
wedding and [ __ ] him a Felix yeah yeah
he's going to Felix wedding I remember
that and Felix's wife got killed and
[ __ ] there was some cheese in it but
some people like that though well
because I mean John Smith said I like
campy Roger morbaugh yeah like I said at
some people and that's fair like I kind
of like the more grounded Bond but I can
see if if you like them were kind of
cheesy or the more kind of retro or
vintage one exactly Zach if you like
Craig man see Living Daylights
that's a good one
what happened
um so I don't know I'm just reading this
okay Danny Rowling said that film where
uh Christian Bale had a meltdown must
have been a [ __ ] show to make yeah which
one is that because I feel like
Christian Bale does that on all of his
movies maybe well maybe not all of them
but
is it well Christian Bale is a method
actor yeah isn't he method
which I'm sure is like a [ __ ]
nightmare for everyone else involved
because you have to like
they have to act like the character like
all the time and you have to interact
with them like the character all the
time so
we still haven't done The Machinist
that's another group speaking Yeah
Christian Bale we need to start this
material we haven't even got on it yet
we're an hour in at least not really I
mean we're kind of I mean we're talking
about we're still talking about the
movies this part of the show we don't
even really have to do this material
I mean we're going to it's a
free-flowing show but you know well yeah
well that's I kind of like these kind of
topics they're they're kind of difficult
in one way because like I said there's
so much info out there that it's it
takes me a long time to kind of like
winnow it down to like a few things that
I want to talk about
but when we do the show it's actually
like a lot less stressful because I
figure well I have like a lot of stories
if we don't get to all of them then
that's okay you know what I mean so you
can just kind of and we can kind of go
up on other tangents about other movies
and things like that because I'm sure
you guys have some likes of [ __ ] too
um
because Sean Smith said no one ever
seems to use method acting to play
anyone nice right that's what I'm that's
the point that I'm making and it's like
everybody that's a method actor it's
like oh that I think they just use that
as an excuse to just walk around like
acting like a [ __ ] ass all the time I
think that's what they want to do
ultimately even though they might not
like admit that to themselves they're
just like I just wanted an excuse I'm
I'm method I'm just going around acting
like a douchebag because that's what my
character is but yeah nobody goes around
acting like a nice person
I don't know I don't know how I feel
about that
Terminator salvation with Christian Bale
okay so that was what we talked about I
don't think I've seen
I don't think I've seen that movie
actually
Pat says you can do the material on the
next show
probably
and let me see if there's anything else
because I'm kind of waiting for him to
come back before I get on it
editor
yeah Zach's saying some of the uh James
Bond movies were uh disasters behind the
scenes but you'd never guess it yeah
that's the thing it's like it always
kind of like amazes me
more when you hear about these horrible
stories that come out and like there
were all this you know there were all
these [ __ ] disasters that happened
behind the scenes but then the movie
still came out good because when I think
about it
you know it's easy for me to like sit
here in my office and like [ __ ] on
movies and everything but so much has to
go right for a movie to come out good
that I'm honestly amazed like when any
movie comes out good because there's
like so much [ __ ] that could totally go
wrong and so much [ __ ] that could
because there's so many moving Parts you
know what I mean and just like one or
two things like being disastrous can
kind of like bring down your whole [ __ ]
you know what I mean so I'm actually
more amazed that there are as many good
movies as there are you know what I mean
you would think that with all the
nightmare that you have to go through to
like make one like you'd think that they
would all suck so so the fact that
there's like actually a lot of good ones
is amazing
um I also love when the behind the
scenes story is more entertaining than
the movie itself like the room yeah
thank you Bryce
thank you very much breaking it off look
at the price breaking it off thank you
my man said agreed I think method acting
is an excuse to be a diva see I'm kind
of like thinking that too because yeah
like so John Smith made the point it's
like no one ever uses a method actor
like when they're playing a nice
character it's always like when they're
a douche or like a serial killer having
acted myself method acting really really
only makes sense on stage
if you're method acting in a movie
you're gonna [ __ ] be shooting
yourself in the foot because you're
constantly doing the same [ __ ] over and
over and over
makes more sense to be just be robotic
be like a robotic liar
that's all yeah because like you said
that's what see that's why I don't think
that I could ever be like an actor like
in movies because I feel like a lot of
it's just [ __ ] tedious man yeah you
have to do the same [ __ ] thing like
over and over some of the [ __ ] that we
did in drama school me me and Graham
and you know Grandpa's he's in he's in
there he was in the same program then
later when I went to Brazil I did some
more leads with like Fantastics and
stuff
you have to brainwash yourself that you
are that that character yeah and it
really helps you in front of a live
audience especially if you've got to
sing numbers because it was always
musicals
and if you're up there in your own
character you you're gonna be under a
lot of [ __ ] stress it's better if
you've convinced yourself you're this
character yeah so he [ __ ] up it's not
on you so you're just going through the
motions of being this character it's
you're channeling it
you know and um you're under a lot less
stress so I think method acting probably
helps with that a lot yeah I could see
that because it's not you anymore you
become that's what they're talking about
how mental illness kicks in a lot if
you're doing that because you're putting
yourself into alter egos or you don't
and all you're doing one job after a net
after the next
pretending to be somebody else
you don't really have much of a
character of your own
you know if you're doing that for
[ __ ] 20 30 years that's what I'm
saying it's like so I'm actually more
surprised that like more actors aren't
just like completely about [ __ ] crazy
because that would drive me crazy
like after a while because you would you
would feel like you wouldn't have an
identity of your own anymore because
you're always like playing someone else
yeah that um
that guy from Elephant Man and [ __ ]
Sansa lamb who was his name [ __ ] uh
Anthony Hopkins Anthony Hopkins he says
it drove him [ __ ] crazy but you could
see that yeah especially if you're
constantly playing like really difficult
characters like he's doing yeah
um you know what I mean or you you have
to play like you know like I said serial
killers or Psychopaths or some [ __ ] like
that yeah that's gonna [ __ ] with your
head I mean you know you're just human
he said he liked to um do little bitty
Off-Broadway plays uh to chill out
because he had instant gratification
from the audience yeah a lot of actors
like that because you want to hear and
feel their reactions to what you're
doing it's the same thing with us doing
this show having that having us having a
having a live stream right there with
the comment section we know what you
guys are feeling we're interacting that
helps a lot
it does it's much easier yeah in some
ways it's easier like I still like worry
that it's like
um you know that I'm gonna [ __ ] up and
there's gonna be dead time and stuff
like that but in some ways it's easier
on the live show like with you than it
is doing recorded stuff just on my own
because like I have somebody spotlights
off yeah you know yeah the spotlight's
on you and there's nothing to bounce
anything off of right you gotta it's one
long guitar solo yeah basically I've
gotten I've kind of gotten used to it
now like because I what I tend to do
though is like I usually have really
good notes and I just pretend that I'm
talking to you guys like even if I'm not
even if I'm just recording it what a
YouTube live stream is is a modern
version of a 1970s talk show like Merv
Griffin
y'all might not be old enough
yeah like Merv Griffin or the Letterman
show there was a live audience he was
bouncing off of and they're talking
about subjects but it's all has to be
condensed into a little bit of time I
think it was
once the commercials pulled out probably
only 35 minutes
35 minutes of material
and there was a stand-up thing in the
introduction in the very beginning this
is really kind of similar to that mixed
with a radio show
because it's like doing them
yeah and mixed with just like kind of
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] but they
bullshitted too and hanging out and
drinking the only reason why they didn't
[ __ ] more back then is because they
were crying they were hurting for time
it was corporate time
if they had unlimited time it would have
been like this they would have gone on
for hours yeah
now they drank on them too
yeah back in the day they drank on those
shows especially the game shows
Hollywood Square they were [ __ ]
loaded on Hollywood Square most of the
time you could see man that [ __ ] was so
funny yeah this guy was [ __ ] funny
you could see him [ __ ] in between
breaks we're turning around like that
[ __ ] drinking like that and putting
that band to bring it to flask yeah
bring the flask yeah yeah Phyllis Diller
[ __ ] built and out of a [ __ ] flask
you know and they're hiding it when the
camera came on her and [ __ ] whatever
Phyllis Diller was in Mad monster party
too yeah that what I just talked about
today it was a little puppet of her yeah
talking like her yeah an old Lind what
was his name Paulin Paul Lynn Paul Lind
would be [ __ ] the Center Square on
the Hollywood Square and he was really
the funniest one he was yeah you guys
don't know who he was he was funny he
was just this real brilliant [ __ ]
flaming gay dude who was just [ __ ]
hilarious he was a legend all right and
his wit was [ __ ] sharp as a razor
and he'd be drunk off his ass
uh well see what happens they they would
record a whole week's worth of [ __ ]
shows in a single session
so you could see as the shows were
coming up by Friday
Lynn was [ __ ] everything it was kind
of like falling asleep
it's been a long day you guys yeah yeah
they're all like [ __ ] yeah
they're all slurring their words
hey what was his name B Arthur wasn't
she in there she might have been yeah
they had like a lot of people on there
yeah what was his name Uncle Walt
they called him I think they called him
Uncle Walt another gay guy hey
miltonborough no it wasn't thinking of
I thought when I think he might have
been I think he might have been the guy
who played uh on Bewitched um
[ __ ] uh Dr Bombay wouldn't it wasn't
he in the Hollywood Squares too if you
guys can help me out there was a guy
like that he was a just another old
Queen
in his 60s and he was [ __ ] funny too
mango said great review of mad monster
party a forgotten animation classic yeah
I was uh I hadn't seen it for a very
long time
and it's kind of sad because it doesn't
get the same it doesn't get the same
play as like all the Rankin bass you
know like Rudolph and Rudolph the
Red-Nosed Reindeer and real shiny new
year and Frosty the Snowman and all that
kind of stuff that you get but it's you
know
it's had [ __ ] Boris Karloff and
Phyllis Diller yeah you know what I mean
and they're like all and they were
monsters it was Dracula and the mummy
and [ __ ] like that yeah I mention of
Foster Brooks yeah
yeah that was like the Golden Era of the
funny drunk yeah funny drunk [ __ ]
Hollywood
[Laughter]
well there was kind of like a whole
it was a whole sub-genre I feel like of
Comedy that was just like people that
were drunk like that were like drunk
bombs the king of them all would be
Buddy Hackett buddy it was just this
[ __ ] drunk make you laugh
[Music]
it's the thing
mango said I have it on DVD I'm assuming
it means mad monster party how to get it
imported from the states yeah you don't
really see it all that much I think that
you didn't see it on TV as much as the
Christmas ones just because it was
longer you know I mean it was like it
was like uh
you know it was feature length it was an
hour and a half which I was surprised
because I didn't remember it being that
long
Richard Brown said Oliver Reed yeah yeah
back in the day man everyone was [ __ ]
drunk yeah it amazes me that they got
the [ __ ] accomplished they got
accomplished as [ __ ] well they wanted
it drunk as they must have been and they
flaunted they flaunted the fact that
they were drunk and high a lot yeah they
didn't have any issue with that in the
70s
they just they were tougher people
they were coming out of the they were
the Boomer jet they were actually post
boom pre-bloom regeneration World War II
style generation they were hard man they
were lucky to be alive
yeah so they were like well I'm just
gonna [ __ ] drink smoke I don't give a
[ __ ] yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
I made it through that [ __ ] [ __ ] it the
rest of the time we're gonna [ __ ]
drink this where to Vacation we're just
gonna party got nothing to lose
yeah I kind of feel like
slasher Fred said one of these days on
your show either on Sunday or Wednesday
you should do a review of the 1972
British classic Tales from the Crypt and
it's follow-up The Vault of horror I've
actually wanted to do those for a while
because they're anthologies and I really
really like horror anthologies I've seen
both of them like multiple times
but yeah we should maybe we should do
like a double feature that'd be neat uh
mango says I'm drunk all hail Oliver
read yeah yeah I mean we're getting
there I'm gonna send him over to your
place and he's gonna take his clothes
off and you're going to wrestle in front
of them in front of the fireplace
and Zach's gonna record that [ __ ]
just on the bare skin rug yeah yeah
he's gonna record direct and record
whole camera crew and everything John
Smith said Oliver Reed died the most
Oliver Reed death ever heart attack arm
wrestling English Sailors after drinking
shots all day okay yeah I mean that's
kind of how we all want to go out really
that's [ __ ] legendary yeah holy [ __ ]
all right so you want to talk about some
of this kind of stuff go ahead so the
first one I want to talk to you might
know something uh maybe a little bit
about this I'm not sure if you do or not
do you know anything about the movie The
Conqueror because
um because I actually feel like Howard
was kind of like involved isn't that
about Genghis Genghis Khan yeah yeah
yeah like with uh John Wayne John Wayne
yeah yeah playing jenga's come yeah
which uh he's in yellow face
yeah that's how you did it back then
this was 1956. yeah it's like I saw it
though We're not gonna like hire an
actual Asian actor to play that
character nobody show up
he wanted John Wayne to be the it's
called acting he's just acting like he's
like
goalie like he's my goal
he's going around [ __ ] all right now
you guys get on top of those horses
[Laughter]
I'm totally Mongolian yeah where
Mongolian as [ __ ] Pilgrim pilgrim
I mean yeah yeah
but yeah so this movie came out in 1956.
um generally regarded as one of the
worst movies ever made I haven't seen it
so I can't really make a judgment call
on that in that uh regard
but the thing about it is that why it
became so famous not because it was like
necessarily like super shitty which I've
heard that it was
but uh it's famous because it was
actually filmed downwind of a nuclear
testing site
and uh several member an alarming number
of cast and crew members later got
cancer yeah and died
yeah uh what actually ended up happening
so the nuclear testing site that we're
talking about uh was the Nevada National
Security Site this was from like 1951 to
1963.
now what they did in 1953 this place was
they called it operation upshot knot
hole which I was like can you think of a
better name than that that's like very
clunky but anyway
um so that whole thing
was they set off 11 atomic bombs in that
area
uh almost all of which were bigger than
the uh Hiroshima bombs yeah
now two of the bombs which they always
gave them names because of course they
did they were expensive yeah and they
had a lot of [ __ ] people watching
them so they had an ever an event to go
watch an atomic bomb go off yeah we're
gonna watch it they're gonna start off
little John okay this is let's watch a
little job this one is like Simon one of
them is named Simon and the other one
was named Harry this one this one's
[ __ ] Big Bertha you know look
first of all y'all are [ __ ] okay
you're all week week generation of
peoples for the younger you are the
weaker you are worried about setting off
these Atomic devices okay so always set
off an atomic bomb that's the end of the
world that you go look at the numbers
the above ground nuclear testing when
you when you put together the United
States the Soviet Union and Europe
because Europe was doing some of it too
they had little islands where they could
sense [ __ ] up I think I think France
France sets some off
I looked at the total number of [ __ ]
above ground nuclear blasts that mankind
together did it was over a hundred they
set off a lot of those things man
lot
so was it good uh no no but they did it
and uh people got cancer
but it wasn't the end of world you know
and the government's new too
but and they they wanted to use it they
wanted to see how sick people would get
how many would die
that's the that was the thinking to give
them an idea what what nuclear warfare
would be like what are the actual risks
but uh no they did it
John Smith says worst yellow face
classic doctor whose Talons of Wang
China my favorite one that's my friend I
remember that episode it's kind of it's
kind of notorious it's a good episode
it's a good well it's it's a it's a that
that story has I think six or seven
episodes in it I like that one but Mr
Singh the [ __ ] homunculus [ __ ]
mechanical Pig braid Little Robot was
going out killing people dressed like a
Chinese and ventriloquist doll
it was good it was what was his name
Magnus greal he was a time traveler from
the 1980s that went yeah Tom has Brett
box you guys yeah yeah I'm watching that
ship yeah
I wanted to be Doctor Who when I was a
little boy I wanted a Tardis and
everything speaking of britbox yeah um
people have been asking us to review
um The Cook the Thief His Wife and Her
Lover and I realized that that is on
britbox you still have ripoff right yeah
okay so maybe I gotta watch the old
[ __ ] Tom Baker maybe we should review
another movie then it was before it was
like hard for me to find but then I saw
it was Brit on brick box I was like oh
you have that yeah so okay I was
watching revenge of the Cybermen yeah
yeah yeah he got britbox just like I
watched like old Doctor Who
old Doctor Who's better than the new
Doctor Who I haven't seen the new doctor
here so I wouldn't know
um I was a big fan the tenant one was
okay
the first dude was better I like
Christopher Eccles yeah he was he was
better well I saw him in a bunch of
other things before I even knew that he
was a doctor who yeah so like I I like
him as an actor yeah you know what I
mean just
now that [ __ ] for me Tom Baker is
always going to be Doctor Who
I mean yeah you're probably not the only
person
but uh but yeah so okay so what were the
okay so the bombs were named Simon and
Harry so like I said
so these two in particular caused a lot
of Fallout
so the Fallout from these two particular
bombs drifted into uh St George Utah
which was about 140 miles away
uh so because of the way the wind blew
and everything like that like a lot of
this Fallout would settle over this area
of Snow Canyon now the year after they
were detonated
uh the movie The Conqueror filmed in
Snow Canyon and they were there for 13
weeks
now Howard Hughes was the producer on
this movie and Bill Powell was the
director
and there is evidence that they knew
about the radiation beforehand and just
said [ __ ] it or at least like at least
Howard Hughes I guess he had gotten some
uh the atomic energy commission they
said oh it's fine it's fine probably no
one will it's it's totally safe
um now John Wayne even back in these
days like John Wayne was like man I
don't really trust that you know so he
brought a geiger counter like picking I
I don't think this is safe as they're
telling me
so uh so basically they had like while
they were filming you know
it's the desert so you know the
temperatures you're gonna get like 120
degrees uh that's Fahrenheit 49 celsius
if you're not American and because of
all of the dust and the dirt that came
up like during filming a lot of some of
which was you know they wanted as part
of the movie so they like had big fans
that were like blowing all the dust
around and stuff
um and everybody would just be like
covered with this [ __ ] dirt and
they'd have to like hose them off at the
end of the day
and um also Howard Hughes at the end of
this shoot like he actually took a bunch
of the radioactive dirt back to Los
Angeles like so they could reshoot like
on back lots and things like that so it
would look the same
now a couple years after the shoot
uh several members of the cast and crew
started getting cancer at uh wildly
inflated rates like you know way way
higher than average
so Bill Powell the director uh John
Wayne
um the woman that played his love
interest uh and one of the co-stars of
Agnes Moorhead was in it uh they all
died of cancer within 25 years of the
movie being released uh there was
another actor named Pedro uh Armin
Armand daris I think he actually uh got
cancer as well and like learned it was
terminal and he killed himself
by 1980 90 members of the 22 the the 220
person crew had gotten cancer and 46 of
them had died that's a lot that's like
very much much higher than average
um yeah this so basically like they did
a study of it and like basically they
said that's about three times the usual
rate
so yeah I mean obviously this was
probably caused by the [ __ ] radiation
so
um now Howard Hughes did not get cancer
but he apparently felt really bad about
this whole [ __ ] show and came out
against nuclear power in his later years
in uh 1957 which was only like a year
after the movie came out he actually
very famously again spent 12 million
dollars of his own money buying all the
existing prints of this movie The
Conqueror
um so no one could see it
because that's how much of a [ __ ] show
it was it was so yeah there's that
so a couple of other these are just kind
of like little short things before we
get into like the main movies that I
want to talk about
um but I wanted to bring up deliverance
from 1972. we have done a review of
Deliverance like a long time ago
but one of the things like a couple of
things that happened behind the scenes
on Deliverance in particular
um James Dickey and John who is the
screenwriter and John Borman who is the
director
um they got in at least one fist fight
so there was that too also they were men
men can't even be around one another
without punching one another they had to
[ __ ] solve the [ __ ] man you wouldn't
understand you wouldn't understand they
[ __ ] maybe they should make sure that
shit's right we understand it's just
that's like what kindergarteners do now
like I says that's how men are gonna
solve that [ __ ] man and also
kindergarteners so
um yeah but John Borman
his big thing
was
he didn't really seem to give a [ __ ]
about it's like this all this like stunt
double business
I want all of my actors there were some
big actors in this right I want them all
to do their own stunts yeah
um Burt Reynolds actually once famously
said he thought that John Borman was
very adamant about filming the movie in
chronological order which they don't
usually do he's like I think that he
wanted us to film in a chronological
order in case one of us dropped it like
in case one of us died like doing one of
the stunts yeah
um
like for Reynolds had that yeah that's a
shout out to Burt Reynolds Burt Reynolds
is it is the the that's the southern
James Bond right there that's the that's
the real James Bond
I mean Burt Reynolds actually was
um injured in Deliverance like he was um
when a canoe like he was in a canoe and
it went over a waterfall and he broke
his tailbone yeah uh Jon Voigt who is
also on the film he um you know the
sequence where he's climbing up the side
of the Rock
he did that for real like no harness no
nothing yeah that was not a stunt double
hey man look [ __ ] Bert also did his
own stunts and white lightning or Gator
or Gator and a white or was it white
lighting or white lighting white
lightning and Gator were the same series
remember that he's hanging on the side
of that car as it's jumping ramping
through the air that was it that was a
crazy [ __ ] stunt and hits the ground
he falls into the sand he he you know he
was an action star man
in his day Burt Reynolds was actually
his mustache would have cushioned the
fall yeah he was Macho Man that's that
that's what women were into women were
into that look women were into that look
back in the 70s he was a man
oh we got somebody I well I guess you're
a new person I've just never seen you in
the chat before uh El padrino please do
a review of The Toxic Avenger we
probably will eventually because I
actually really like that movie we
should probably do more Sharon by now I
don't think about it uh also I caught
your video where you mentioned ashita
Kim and laughed for hours was that was
that the bullshito Bushido yeah yeah I
mean we've talked about the cheetah came
on more than one but yeah that was like
the main show that we did about it yeah
Kim lived in a time he's still around
but he was doing his thing at a time
before the the mainstream public knew
what LARPing was okay that
motherfucker's LARPing LARPing well he's
so he was like ahead of his time he was
ahead of his time is what you're saying
he's ahead of his time
LARPing is a ninja promoting the karate
magazines and selling VHS VHS tapes to
14 year olds he he made a whole [ __ ]
career and it worked yeah and we're
still talking about him now so I guess
he had some kind of success he did not
survive the internet because everybody
called because everybody called his
[ __ ] out over time
cheetah Kim
I mean you can still get away with
[ __ ] nowadays but you have to come
at it from a different angle totally
different angle yeah you can't you can't
your [ __ ] can't fly like I think he
believed his own [ __ ] though I think
I really kind of like I don't know like
I I mean I know like a a bit about him
because I researched and run the show
and he really does seem to be somebody
that bought into his own yeah he was a
little bit mentally ill I think uh yeah
he did strikes delusional fantasy prone
delusional character thought he was a
Special Forces Ninja
I mean he sold VHS tapes of how to duck
underneath Windows like that is a
[ __ ] ninja technique how to crouch
that was my favorite how to throw dirt
in somebody's face that's a [ __ ]
ninja technique you know
get the [ __ ] out holy [ __ ] I never would
have thought of that yeah yeah how about
you just like run away from the danger
oh my God so dirt in somebody's face
that's how you disappear okay yeah yeah
that's basically what Batman does but
when you think about it he's not that's
true it's kind of make some smoke and
then run and everybody thinks you
disappeared that's how Batman would have
done it you know
and then like you're still standing
there like well the Batman character was
written to where he couldn't have any
guns so he couldn't just mow people down
like like a scene maybe like so much
well that'd be simple because it's too
easy it's too easy nobody would watch
that right yeah that's boring go up
against [ __ ] seven armed men with all
with guns and you got smoke bombs and
fists but that's a superhero that's the
superhero Motif you know
El padrino office that I was going
through your videos I thought you guys
would have done something on Jonestown
we did
I mean we mentioned Joe and Sam no we
did a show about Jonestown and it wasn't
that long ago I mean it's hard for me to
say because my sense of time is all
[ __ ] up but I remember doing a show
I'm pretty sure we did a show about
Jonestown while we were in this house so
it must have been within a year within a
last year because we've only lived in
this house for like a little over a year
so I'm pretty sure we've done it since
then so in the past year it did
um he also said I lived as a kid in the
80s in Chicago there was a karate school
on every block yeah I'm sure he inspired
some of those guys yeah it was like very
very big
yeah well you know um
Cal Dante was from Chicago yeah
they were uh they were called the
Chicago Dojo Wars if I remember
correctly that was back in the 70s
which brought in all these [ __ ] ideas
like from [ __ ] you know karate kid
you know
where you got Cobra Kai fighting [ __ ]
Miyagi dough and [ __ ] you know that
that's that that came from
that came from uh those [ __ ] man
this Maniacs from [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] what was the name of his little
[ __ ] they were called the black
dragon black dragon Society black dragon
Society fighting Society black dragon
fighting Society that's what it was
called and it was uh it was it was
[ __ ]
advertised in every [ __ ] Marvel comic
that we had we were looking yeah it was
always in the back of the comic black
dragon fighting with the count Dante
doing this thing and hit his afro
he was a white dude with an afro
he was a hairdresser that's how he
really made his money and he had a dojo
[ __ ] [ __ ] man truth is Stranger Than
Fiction
and I've seen interviews with some of
his former students they said he was
great it's great that the [ __ ] Dojo
was great and they [ __ ] had a great
time
and when you think about it it was like
a prototype of MMA is what they were
doing kind of like MMA
alpatrania said do you remember a show
called Specter man yeah I remember the
name
I don't remember that picture I
mentioned more about it I could Spectrum
man I think was
an American name for a Japanese product
I think Spectrum man was started off as
a Japanese thing that kind of does sound
like something
yeah Spectrum man I think was
wait a minute Spectrum man I'm gonna run
to the bathroom go ahead okay hold on
why don't you play once you play your uh
hold on because you were talking okay
Spectrum man I think might have been
that Filipino or Indonesian version of
uh of uh Ultraman
I think you can see that free I think
it was like a high quality Indonesian or
not Indonesian Filipino or Taiwanese I
think it might have been Taiwanese
the camp guy mentioned Ultraman
Camp guys calling it Ultraman
it wasn't spectrum and Ultraman were two
different things
um but I'd have to be reminded more of
what Spectra man was I'd have to go look
and see it and it might jog my memory
it's not Ultraman
Spectrum man was something different
I think it might have been
the Taiwanese knockoff
of Ultraman which I think there's only
just one movie if I remember correctly I
don't think it was a series I think it
was a movie
if that's the one I'm thinking of and it
was actually a pretty good movie
all right Pat says if I'm remembering
right Spectrum man had an awesome theme
song or by misremembrane
El Padilla comes in with two gorillas
one blonde hair
gorilla and and
but with one blonde hair gory
and the car is the gorilla I don't
remember that
foreign
yeah I don't remember I don't remember
that Spectrum ahead he had two gorillas
nah I remember this name I really had
two girls yeah he had two gorillas a
black gorilla and another one of them
was a blonde gorilla I don't remember
and what was it brunette yeah he had a
blind I don't I don't remember I had to
see it I remember the name Spectrum man
I watched it but I don't I don't
remember it that well
yeah
that's like very funny it was it was a
cartoon or live action
hmm okay
yeah I don't think I ever saw that I
mean it's it's hardly possible that I
watched it but
I watched so much stuff when I was a kid
like
sometimes I don't remember it unless
somebody like brings it up you know
all right so uh oh another one I wanted
to talk about just very briefly was Roar
if you guys haven't seen this one I came
out in 1981.
and uh this movie often gets described
as one of the most dangerous movies ever
made
uh directed by a guy named Noel Marshall
and it was about a family
um and they interacted with lions
and um and they were real lions and
pretty much like 70 I think at least
like 70 uh cast and crew members got
injured on this set
so Noel Marshall who's the director is
also in the movie also has Tippy hedron
you know famous for being in the birds
the Alfred Hitchcock movie and Melanie
Griffith I think she was only a teenager
or maybe in her early 20s she was like
pretty young this was like kind of
before her big like breakout role and uh
so the three of them like Stars this
family that kind of live alongside like
lions and tigers and like other animals
in Africa right
now
um Noah Marshall the director and star
of the movie uh you know was obviously
like well we have to use real animals
and um you know obviously animals gonna
animal and they're not super predictable
so uh Marshall actually got bit by a
lion like uh bit like all the way
through his hand
that was actually on the first day
Melanie Griffith uh got attacked by a
lion and had to get 50 stitches
uh and she also had to go uh have facial
reconstruction surgery because the you
know lying bitter in the face
also Tippy hedron uh broke her leg and
her hand uh after an elephant uh threw
her off its back
and she also got attacked by a lion and
had to get uh 38 stitches in her scalp
because the lion like grabbed her by the
head so there's that and honestly the
movie's like pretty batshit crazy if
you've never seen it um
I'm not really sure why it was made but
yeah uh
but but it's interesting nonetheless
like I said Melanie Griffith's very very
early one of her early roles and she got
[ __ ] up by a lion at it as did
everyone else okay I see a spectrum man
they got the complete series on on
YouTube yeah
um I vaguely remember this one but I
don't think it was uh I don't think it
was
I don't think it was widely available
where I was living
I had I had this one
um
the one I was confusing with I think
it's called infra man
which is which is a movie
let me see I saw that
yeah it's good
infoman
see if that's on YouTube
what was the name of that movie remember
that movie we watched a couple years ago
that was just like the craziest [ __ ]
ever that was just like kind of like
kind of a kung fu movie and then there
was like a guy that was supposed to be
Clint Eastwood in it and then there was
mommies and then there was uh
Laurel and Hardy No Abbott Costello
something
yeah they got the full infoman on there
on YouTube you might want to see oh [ __ ]
it's Whited it all out you want to see
if you want to see him for man that's a
good one that's a real good one it's uh
it's it's Taiwanese I think
and it's it's like uh yeah there you go
it's kind of like it's kind of like
Ultraman
my friend put this up there and he did
all the subtitles for it the subtitles
are really good
he was part of robot Japan which is like
a collector's group that collects
Japanese stuff and he did this one
Superman
John Smith said I know the main Lion in
Roar was Anton lavey's Old Lion oh okay
I didn't know that
yeah she Melanie Griffith did have to
have a facial reconstruction surgery
because the lion bit her in the face uh
Camp guy said you they say you'll never
even uh hear it if a mountain lion
stalks and attacks you they attack an
unwary prey from behind which makes
sense if you think about it because
they're just like looking for food you
know what I mean
uh L Petrino said I liked your video on
Bob Lazar that was some funny [ __ ]
that was a fun show I remember doing
that one
remember that show we did about Bob
Lazar yeah
yeah Mr 88 said uh Tippy hedron is
Melanie Griffith's mom yeah that's right
I forgot I totally forgot about that
they had pet lions around their house
there were many pictures of them with
big cats online so I guess they were
just trying to make because mango was
saying it's like kind of like a
semi-documentary I think that's kind of
what it was they're like oh look how
cool it is to like have pet lions like
around your house until you know it's
all fun and games until a lion bites
your face off I guess but that's kind of
what happened on the set
so there was that
um also I wanted to mention uh Titanic
somebody mentioned the abyss earlier
like the James Cameron movie and like I
said anytime you're like filming on the
water and James Cameron is notorious for
wanting everything to be as realistic as
possible so obviously they're gonna like
submerge the actors in water tanks and
you know they get the flu and [ __ ] like
that
um also I think one of the most famous
things that happened on the set of
Titanic was that one crew member for
whatever reason I guess because they
thought it would be funny
um spiked some soup I think it was clam
chowder with PCP oh man why would that
be funny I mean it was funny to the
person that did it I guess not so funny
to the 50 people that had to go to the
hospital so subsequently [ __ ] gnarly
drug man I mean that's just kind of like
I don't know you have to have a pretty
[ __ ] up sense of humor to be like
wanting to do that
because I kind of feel like it's one of
those things where
you know it's kind of similar to LSD
where it's like you know if you're
taking it and you know you're taking it
and you know like what it's gonna yeah
then yeah it's gonna be a fun time for
it right but if like somebody just slips
it to you and you have no idea then
you're gonna have a bad time you're
gonna have this yeah you're gonna freak
out you're gonna freak out
said the worst horror movie of all time
eaten alive I've kind of been wanting to
do a review on that but I haven't seen
it in a long time because it well
there's two there was a Toby Hooper one
and then there was another one
so I'm not really sure like right next
to that piece of crap Mickey blue eyes
I've heard of that but I don't think
I've ever seen it
I don't think I've ever seen it all
right so let's start talking about
The Wizard of Oz because a lot of crazy
we got a plug and do commercials this
episode okay well yeah I can do that
I just I you know I had to go to the
bathroom but then you were talking and I
didn't want to like it I could have
waited till after
yes Pat said which okay so the Toby
Hooper one is the one you're talking
about yeah yeah the Toby Hooper wouldn't
have the alligator in it and then there
was like a cannibal one too yeah but I
haven't seen the Tokyo for one in a long
time the alligator yeah okay
I think it's on shutter
so Wizard of Oz
this is another movie that has also been
called one of the most dangerous films
ever made because all kind of crazy [ __ ]
went on behind that
um now obviously there weren't a lot of
like stunts or anything like that but
there was all kind of crazy [ __ ] going
on and as we brought up earlier
the movie came out in 1939 they didn't
really have a great deal of protections
for the actors at the time so they just
kind of like did whatever
um as we mentioned earlier there was a
movie called under the rainbow that sort
of like was a comedy about the actors
that were playing the munchkins how much
of this is true I don't know because as
someone pointed out earlier like Judy
Garland said a lot of this stuff and you
know she was kind of famously
um you know hi yeah a lot of the time so
I so I don't know like how true a lot of
this stuff is but apparently a lot of
the little people that worked on The
Wizard of Oz were
um drunk all the time and would do a
bunch of uh
I guess like orgies and stuff like in
the hotel that they were staying at
there was like all kind of like [ __ ]
little people were dude going on uh I
think it was called the Culver Hotel
where they were staying at I heard uh
some of the some of the little people
afterwards said that it wasn't that they
made it into something that it wasn't
that it wasn't that big of a dude that's
kind of yeah it's it could be that like
it's kind of become legendary over time
that they were doing all kind of crazy
[ __ ]
um the interview that I saw with one of
the what was one of the women that said
that it was the same thing other people
do you had some people that were [ __ ]
around other people most people were
just trying to get through the work day
and uh but yeah they were they were
drinking and having parties but she said
it wasn't anything unusual well and I
kind of feel like if the regular size
people had been doing that like nobody
would have said anything yeah there's
like oh it's the little people doing it
so that makes it funnier that's what she
said right she said it was like well
we're not children
they're right you know [ __ ] we're
older than you right you know it's that
kind of it's that kind of deal so that
might have been like what it was I kind
of suspected right
uh one story said though that one of the
munchkin actors got stuck in a toilet
bowl
like during uh he got lunch uh he got it
was the lunch break and he got drunker
and he got stuck in there and had
somebody had to pull him out I don't
know if that's true or not
but that was How The Story Goes uh so
apparently the cops got called like
several times to this hotel because they
were like acting up you know what I mean
um so as I said I don't know if how true
any of that is I'm sure it's probably
exaggerated but um I kind of feel like
poor Judy Garland
she was very young when she made this
movie she was only 16 17 something like
that Hollywood [ __ ] her up too big
time they got her hooked on all kinds of
[ __ ] drugs to keep her skinny
yeah ridiculous but that's how they were
back then that's what I'm saying yeah
yeah I mean well at this time and we
kind of talked about this when we were
talking about like the Golden Era of
Hollywood shows that we've done is that
unlike nowadays where actors are more or
less free agents back then you signed a
contract with a particular Studio
whether it was Universal or MGM or
whatever and you kind of had to do what
they said or they would fire you or kick
you or penalize you in some way yeah
they had her on methamphetamine
they did yeah
and that happened a lot like and it
wasn't just adults either because like I
said she was just a teenager yeah and
they basically like well um they would
want them to work really long hours so
they would give them adrenaline shots
yeah um and they would give them like
you know barbiturates to keep to like
knock them out to knock them out yeah
and they would do that to Judy and they
would give you stuff like for weight
loss and Hollywood doctors yeah now I
mean Judy Garland like I said she'd
already kind of been pill popping before
Wizard of Oz because you know that was
just what you did back then but once she
got on Wizard of Oz
um you know they started giving her more
stuff and they started putting more diet
pills um giving her diet pills too like
to keep her skinny you look at some of
these people in these old films they
look really old for their age and I
think a lot of it had to do with the
drug use probably yeah there was it was
rampant yeah people think 70s had to do
with drug and [ __ ] no 1800s in the 1800s
hundreds [ __ ] half of America was
either high on coke and the other half
was high on [ __ ] more on [ __ ] on
downers on morphine
uh morphine or cook or cocaine they were
doing it back in the 1800s so by the
time the 1900s had rolled around they
were into all kinds of weird [ __ ] and
they didn't consider them drugs really
they didn't think of it as anything
elicit they weren't even expensive
you know FDA wasn't around yet it was
totally wide open you can just go to a
store and just buy morphine
buy [ __ ] cocaine I think that wasn't
until the [ __ ] I think maybe what 30s
or the 40s they started to control that
huh
I had to go back and look at it but it
was still accepted you know what I mean
people making them Holly the Hollywood
had their own lawyers their own cops
if they owned the police
uh they own all the court system in
California I mean they covered up some
murders yeah they could kill you and
[ __ ] you'd never hear anything of it
they uh [ __ ] deep clause in any
governor of California
um they could do whatever they wanted
thank you Aaron thank you very much just
getting here figured I'd pay a late fee
yeah
thank you so much that's awesome
so uh you know if Hollywood wanted some
Starlet to be skinny over the next
couple years they had they had their own
doctors to write out any kind of
prescription nobody would ask anything
you know
they were powerful and they were
dangerous they were gangsters basically
well like I said at this on Wizard of Oz
uh you know Judy Garland was only 16 17
years old and very famously behind the
scenes uh the producers and [ __ ] like
that called her the fat little pig with
pigtails that's what they called it Judy
Garland yeah damn and she wasn't fat she
went fat but they were just weird I mean
this is this is a world where [ __ ]
Errol Flynn was able to buy a 15 year
old sex slave basically from her parents
he'd have her [ __ ] it up in the house he
had a special
two-way mirror the above the bed he'd
have all his friends come over and [ __ ]
her and he'd sit up there and watch and
[ __ ] it was a [ __ ] weird time man I
mean there was all kind of [ __ ] all
kinds of weird [ __ ] was going on that I
think was like more in a way it was like
more not it wasn't more acceptable just
you know generally it was just like
people didn't they just kind of looked
the other way yeah either yeah either
they didn't know about it or they
couldn't comprehend it or they're just
like well yeah
15 like well yeah they didn't they
didn't have they didn't really have a
strong notion of being underage in the
early 1900s anyway that wasn't really a
thing in Most states you could marry a
girl probably about 13. you know so I
don't they didn't really have a
pedophilia concept I don't believe and
some of the stuff when you looked at
Shirley Temple the way she's filmed and
everything and certain things that
happened in The Little Rascals
they kind of [ __ ] we're selling these
children as kind of like sex symbols
they did sexualize them yeah yeah
you know if I can
Spanky and Alfalfa trying to get a date
off of Miss Crabtree you know [ __ ]
you know that was you know that's kind
of funny you know what I mean but you
wouldn't joke around with that nowadays
you know yeah that would be like people
would be like
certain things in Shirley Temple movies
she's basically being
shocked as if she is in a a miniature
adult
sex symbol in a in a way that she's
Ultra cute and hey you know
she's kind of available and she you know
that's really the way that that was kind
of shot and adult guys are kind of like
you know professing love to her you know
in certain scenes you know it's supposed
to be innocent
but you could interpret it other way
it's a little bit creepy yeah it's a
little bit creepy it's just kind of like
remember the show that we did about
Lewis Carroll and his thing with like
Alice Liddell like who Alice in
Wonderland was sort of based on it's
like you know even if it was innocent at
the time like even if it's still like
from from the perspective of nowadays
it's still it seems pretty creepy I'm
not sure it was all that innocent I
don't think it was either it seems
pretty because why would a grown man
like that's not your daughter that's not
like it just seems like a just a weird
it's because situation
in the early 1900s there was no concept
of childhood
everyone was basically yeah I get that
they were working in minds and doing
[ __ ] it was they were just I think they
just considered them to be smaller
adults and look how cute that is they're
like us
you know that that was seemed to be what
they were I mean little kids smoked
yeah you know they walk around [ __ ]
cigarette coming out of their mouth and
he's like [ __ ] seven
six you know smoking
so you know
it was just another world you know
so I guess if you were I mean according
to Albert Fish you know what I mean
[ __ ] he was he was [ __ ] children
too
you know now he was from around that
time
so it was going on
well yeah of course I gotta do is just
look at what I'm just saying that
doesn't make it right because what was
happening in orphanages and stuff you
know and yeah that was like [ __ ]
horrifying so you know
they did it they didn't really have any
like you said they didn't really have
any concept of like a kid is like a
different than an adult no which is I
don't think that's a good like they saw
them as miniature helpless adults
that they could kind of play with I
guess
El paternity said I was going to say
Alfalfa but everyone stated that he was
just an [ __ ] yeah I heard that too
yeah like I heard that Alfalfa was like
a huge [ __ ] like even when he was a
kid which is terrible I kind of feel
like we should probably do a show about
Little Rascals like a couple years back
it's probably like a couple years ago
now but um me and Tom got like on a kick
where we were just like watching like
all the Little Rascals like shorts back
in the day but I think like Spanky was
probably my favorite but
there's some of those were pretty funny
but yeah like from
from a modern standpoint they are like
pretty weird I understand that that was
like almost 100 years ago and like the
culture was a lot different but
I don't know I do kind of feel it is
weird that we were talking about Shirley
Temple just now because I think
initially they wanted Shirley Temple to
play Dorothy in Wizard of Oz because I
think initially they wanted like Dorothy
in the book I think it's like a younger
character I think they wanted her to be
more like a 12 year old
um which I think is one of the reasons
that they were like
kind of like uh you know riding Judy
Garland so hard about like not getting
like bigger or like you know staying
thin and everything because they wanted
her to look more like a 12 year old even
just she's clearly honestly when I was
growing up and I was watching Wizard of
Oz because I saw Wizard of Oz like a
million times when I was a kid
I actually thought that Judy Garland was
older than a teenager like I thought she
was just like supposed to be a teenager
like a young adult and I was actually
surprised when I found out that she was
only 17 in that movie because to me she
looked older than that
but
I don't know I mean she definitely
doesn't look like a kid they wanted her
to look more like a 12 year old but she
clearly does not look like a 12 year old
yeah in Wizard of Oz yeah I I was just
saying that it's like I was actually
surprised that I found out she was only
17 because I thought she was probably in
her early 20s in that movie but she's
not she's only 17. yeah she looks a lot
older she does but they actually wanted
initially they wanted Shirley Temple to
be in that movie because they wanted
like a more 12 year old looking kid
which like I said was probably why they
were like getting on her case so much
about like not gaining any weight
um another thing you're skinny wouldn't
make her look younger though well that's
what I'm saying it's just like I don't
know it's pretty thin in it so she but I
mean she's just normal size yeah she's
not she looks like a 20 year old though
like you said I thought yeah I thought
she looks older than 17 like in the in
the movie she's cute though she's cute
she is but she doesn't look like a kid
she doesn't look like a child I mean you
know people kind of seemed like they
matured a little faster I think then did
you notice that
yeah but remember we were talking about
old-fashioned we were talking about that
like on another show I there's actually
a really good I can't remember what the
name of the channel was now but I saw a
really good YouTube video a couple weeks
ago about why people perceive
um that people looked older like back in
the old days because remember it's like
I'd always like look at my parents
yearbooks and I'd look at like the
graduating seniors and it'd be like holy
crap they all look like they're 35. you
know what I mean but I don't know if
it's necessarily just because I think
partially it's to do with their health
choices yeah you know what I mean it's
like you know they went out in the sun
more they smoked more they drank more
you know there was they weren't as aware
of Health terrible diet yeah like [ __ ]
like that so I'm sure that contributed
but I think the other part of it is
probably like hairstyles clothing [ __ ]
like that he was making the argument
that some of it might be that we
associate certain types of clothing with
people of certain ages so even if we see
people that are younger wearing these
particular clothing that we've
associated with older people they're
gonna come across as older to us which
like that made a lot of sense to me
actually
he's a yeah he wasn't saying that that
was the only thing he said yeah
obviously like People's Health choices
back then was like a big factor also
but I generally think people look much
younger nowadays than they did back then
most of them smoked
especially the men
their their diet when you looked at
their [ __ ] food triangle that they
had was exact opposite what you mostly
needed
they always made that damn food triangle
fit what they had at the time so it was
mostly grains and Grains and cereal eat
all the bread we've got lots of bread
just laying around yeah and then there's
a little slab of vegetables and a little
slab of meat because that's what they
had so what you're talking about is high
carb fairly low protein uh that's not a
good diet you know [ __ ] not real good
for cellular regeneration you know
cellular growth
you you throw all that vegan [ __ ]
[ __ ] vegetarian [ __ ] you want at
me go talk to those North Koreans ones
that have never eaten meat
they're [ __ ] six seven inches shorter
than a South Korean all right and they
don't live that long and they look
pretty damn rough for their age you know
that no
low protein and no protein is very bad
for you
that's why there aren't any [ __ ] real
now go ahead well the thing is I mean
you don't necessarily have to eat meat
to get protein because there's protein
and lots of food but animal protein is
special though you're you evolve to eat
it it's it's better for you it
um okay good
uh John Smith said life was tough back
then Steve McQueen looked 40 in his 20s
yeah he did a lot of actors did yeah he
looked old in the blob I need I mean I
know he was older he was supposed to be
playing a high school student which
obviously no
um but I don't think he was as old as he
looked in that movie like we reviewed
the blob like the original one not too
long ago and
I was watching it again it's kind of
like a joke from all those movies from
the 50s and everything like that like
how [ __ ] old like all the teenagers
looked in there but to be fair like most
of those actors were probably only in
their 20s which is about the same as
what they would do nowadays like they
would have actors that were in their 20s
like early to mid 20s like playing
teenagers in high school or whatever but
back then they all were in their 20s but
they looked like they were like 35 years
old there was no teenage culture really
I mean they all dressed like adults they
dress like adults from children almost
there's children clothes and then
immediately became adult at like [ __ ]
10 you know
so that's part of it
well yeah I think that will I think that
was why that there was such a big
cultural shift like in the 50s because
that was the first time that like
Teenage culture had been distinct yeah
from the adult culture you can't really
have teenage culture until you have a
middle class that's really yeah you have
to have a Leisure Time middle class kids
in schools they have to be in a safe
enough environment where they're not out
there working all the time and they can
play and
[ __ ] be kids you know and then
they'll they'll develop a teenager
culture that's what you know you see
that same thing in other countries other
cultures
yeah John Smith said the three pack a
day smoking habit probably put a few
years on a chat back then
yeah I mean they just they smoked like
chimneys they didn't have a great diet
they didn't one of those dudes dead by
40. you know they drank more than they
should you know I'm not gonna get too
much into that because I drink a lot too
but it's just kind of like I mean they
were drinking a lot like every day yeah
and you know it's not like they were out
like you know running around the block
or you know running on the treadmill or
anything or going to the gym or anything
like that they weren't doing any of that
their diets weren't that good and they
didn't have sunblock no either yeah but
I don't think that mattered in most of
the country depending on where they
lived because you know up north they
don't get them they get it's summertime
they get a lot but it's not the same as
the down south
um and that another thing is if you look
to the statistics a lot of them died
behind the wheel
yeah a lot of there were car accidents
were [ __ ] those cars were dangerous
they didn't survive [ __ ] impacts well
they killed they killed you if you hit
anything because they were just they
didn't crumple at all
uh they were driving drunk constantly
uh-huh the cars weighed a lot they
didn't stop very well they didn't have
any like safety no you know they didn't
have like [ __ ] airbags so mortality
was high
and uh
just
they were lucky to make it to 40. until
later what's once the [ __ ] 50s and
once the 60s rolled around mortality's
improved quite a bit
mortality rates well people started to
get more aware of that you could die
yeah you know what I mean and like
things you could do to like extend your
life yeah
El padrino said is that Spock in the
background yes it's Mirror Universe it's
a Mirror Universe spot because evil
Spock well he wasn't evil he was just
mirror yeah he's Mirror Universe I
thought it was a stand-up poster ability
Williams Colt 45
that would be rad if somebody could find
something like that we actually did a
show
um how many it was probably like a few
months ago where we talked about that
because we had some of that we bought
some Colt 45 we were like doing a taste
test on one of them Friday night shows
not bad actually Universal bro it's
actually pretty good yeah if anybody
sends me ability I'll put Billy D up
there
but rotate them out yeah right next to
spock they can hang out together yeah
they can hang out together
but yeah seriously
um okay so yeah we were talking about
Judy Garland so like all the stuff they
gave her because they said she was fat
which is terrible and uh so yeah she
just got addicted to the drug and she
never got over that really she just
stayed on that ship forever those
[ __ ] brains were jelly by the time
she died well that does not surprise me
like I said she died she was three years
younger than me when she died she was 47
years old which is [ __ ] crazy and she
was on meth that whole [ __ ] time I
mean like I said I felt really so bad
for her we should probably do a whole
show about her as a matter of fact
um also and like I said I don't know if
this is true or not but she did actually
make some allegations later on and this
is what we were talking about before
that like a lot of the little people
actors that were acting all crazy and
everything
um that some of them also
uh maybe sexually harassed her as well
like actually her husband said that they
would like come up to and like put their
hands under her dress and like [ __ ] like
that and these are like older you know
they're in their 40s or whatever so
they're doing that because
of at least according to her husband
um you know uh Sid left he said well you
know they were little people they
thought they could get away with
anything so they would just like go
around like sticking their hands up
people's skirts and [ __ ] like that so
like what I'm little I'm cute it's like
not you know what I mean I'm like still
not dogs do the same [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] regular size people do the same
thing we got friends that are little
people well I know that but I'm just big
egos bro
I know that but so I'm just saying
that's still [ __ ] up don't go around
sticking your hand under people's skirts
Jesus Christ back in those days you
could do that I mean well back in those
days if you were friends with a girl you
could smack her on the ass
yeah but she didn't like it she just had
to put up with it because there was
nothing you could do about it that was
the that was the difference it's like if
you talked about it people think and you
know don't complain about it it's like
they don't like it any better than
people like it nowadays but it's like
they just you just couldn't say anything
what's that poke
but yeah so uh so there was all that
going on and she wasn't a big fan of
that and as I said also um Shirley
Temple they wanted Shirley Temple
originally but they thought maybe that
they didn't really love her singing
voice so that's uh you know so that's
kind of why they didn't get her but yeah
Judy Garland they asked her to lose
12 pounds like before she did the film
so like I said that was one of the
reasons they kept like pumping her up
with
um with drugs uh they encouraged her to
start smoking I don't know if she smoked
before the movie but they definitely
said because that was like a big thing
back then too it's like oh well and I
think like a lot of cigarettes back in
the old days like um their advertising
campaigns would get that it's like it's
kind of like an appetite suppressant
right so that was like one of the things
that they
touted as one of the health benefits of
cigarettes it's like oh if you get
hungry you can just like smoke a
cigarette and it'll take your appetite
away so they encourage her to start
smoking uh they actually did put a
corset on her
um that like flattened her boobs like
like I said so she would look younger
because like I said she was you know a
teen older teenager she was 17 and they
wanted her to look like a child which
she obviously did not
um and then two I think initially they
wanted her to be a blonde because they
thought
um that was kind of like the original
look of the character but they thought
maybe she'd look younger if her hair was
darker
um there was another another story about
this about this shoe too
was there's
um kind of like you know one of the
better known scenes in the movie where
Dorothy actually like slaps the Cowardly
Lion like she kind of does his nose like
that and I guess she kept [ __ ] up the
takes because she kept like cracking up
um and she couldn't finish the scene and
then so apparently
um the director like came in and like
hauled up and smacked her across the
face because she kept messing up the
shoot so there was that like for a man
coming in slapping a teenage girl so
there's that
um also probably one of the most famous
accidents that happened on the on the um
set of Wizard of Oz was that
when the Wicked Witch of the West
when she's you know leaving munchkin
land like in the big pluma smoke or
whatever and there was kind of a thing
where uh Margaret Hamilton would be like
lowered down this trapdoor right so she
would disappear
um the whole like the explosions and the
smoke and everything the pyrotechnics
were set off too early and the trapdoor
also malfunctioned like at the same time
so Margaret Hamilton the actor is
playing the Wicked Witch of the West uh
her makeup and her brim and her hat
caught fire
um and her face and hands got like
really really burned like really badly
um so she's like all burned all over and
then like the Medics had to run and they
had to take all the makeup she was all
green like all over right and so they
had to come in and like use alcohol to
get all the makeup off and that was like
super painful too because obviously
she's burned all over and they're trying
to take all this makeup off
um and the makeup
like I said they don't have
this makeup I don't even know what the
[ __ ] it was made out of but it was not
only was it flammable but it was also
toxic you know so she accidentally
Margaret Hamilton actually swallowed
some of it and
um it made her like it [ __ ] her mouth
up she like she couldn't eat for several
days and her skin was also dyed green
because the makeup had like copper in it
which is you know toxic you're not
supposed to put it on your skin so like
I said they didn't give a rat's ass
about the [ __ ] so she like her whole
[ __ ] face and hand caught on fire and
they're like trying to get [ __ ]
makeup offer with alcohol and it's just
like how long has the show been going on
um what two hours and 12 minutes okay
soon I'm going to go down and start
putting the chicken in the in the oven
okay but we still got a long way to go
though yeah so we talked it all away Man
shows how long the show gonna be five
hours well I don't know okay
quit changing the subject
[Laughter]
Mr 88 said yeah there are pics of her
with blonde hair as Dorothy yeah I've
seen those
John Smith said advertising way back way
back when smoke it's good for you yeah
El padrino said did someone actually
hang themselves on the set of Wizard of
Oz no that is an urban legend
but it's a pretty persistent one it's a
pretty persistent one but um as far as I
know that didn't really happen but yeah
that's it's a pretty popular urban
legend
um the thing about it too is that
Margaret Hamilton she got like horribly
burned like I said she had like the
toxic makeup and everything and then
when she finally because she was out for
a while and then like she had to come
back to work and they said oh by the way
we need you to film this surrender
Dorothy scene uh you know which is her
flying on the brim where she like writes
it in the sky and
um that also had like some pyrotechnics
and stuff and Margaret Hamilton probably
understandably was like absolutely not
I'm not doing that so um you know it's
got a little trauma about that so her
stunt double whose name is Betty Danko
she came in and took over and it so
happened that Betty Danko the stunt
double when she was doing this [ __ ] she
got the same thing happen like the
pyrotechnics also malfunctioned a little
bit and she also got burned and had to
be hospitalized so Margaret Hamilton was
like woo dodged a bullet there but you
know what I mean
somebody else got hurt on too so that's
pretty pretty shitty
so also
um what happened here too I think Ray
Bolger
um who he was initially I believe he was
initially hired to play the Tin Man but
he thought he wanted to be the Scarecrow
so they let him be the Scarecrow so they
gave the part of the Tin Man initially
to Buddy Ebsen
but the Silver makeup that they put on
the Tin Man
had aluminum powder in it again very
toxic
now uh Buddy Ebsen actually had a really
really bad allergic reaction to the
aluminum powder
um and he had to be hospitalized also
they had to put him in an oxygen tent
and everything like that
uh the thing about it though was that I
guess like a lot of the people that were
working on the movie didn't know why
Buddy Ebsen left the movie like nobody
they didn't really let it get around
it's like oh it was because of the
Silver makeup
now because of the way that the studio
contracts were kind of
around at the time they actually gave
the part like after Buddy Ebsen got hurt
and he left they gave it to Jack Haley
they basically said well you have to
take this roll now you're contractually
obligated and at that point like they
switched it they're like oh well maybe
we should make this like an aluminum
paste which was maybe a little bit
better than the powder but um Jack
Haley's still got an eye infection from
it because you know like I said they
didn't really have any safeguards
in play like with any of this makeup or
anything and it was like all kind of
toxic [ __ ] [ __ ] in it
um so yeah also
um and I think somebody brought this up
earlier but you know the scene with the
with the poppies like where the witch
puts them all to sleep and they fall
asleep like out in the poppy fields
like the um Dorothy and Toto and the
Cowardly Lion in them
um and then they get woken up by snow
falling on them uh that snow was made of
asbestos
which uh you know I kind of feel like
you know how they used to have
um probably back I think from like from
like the 1930s to like the 1940s you had
like that kind of spray snow or fake
snow
um that was usually made of asbestos
like during about that 20-year period
before they really knew how harmful it
was uh so people like would put it in
their houses like for Christmas
decorations and [ __ ] like that and they
used it in movies a lot including in The
Wizard of Oz
um because it wasn't until much later
that they figured out that it was a
carcinogen
so uh you know so that happened as well
you had like [ __ ] cancers now falling
on them
also Bert Lahr who played the Cowardly
Lion
um his costume was made of real lion
pelts so this costume uh reportedly
weighed about 90 pounds
and smelled really really bad like
especially because you know you have an
actor in there who's like sweating his
ass off every day like on a movie set
and uh you know so and basically like it
took like a really long time like to put
all this stuff on as well all the makeup
and costuming took so long matter of
fact that all three actors like the
Scarecrow the Cowardly Lion and the Tin
Man
um they weren't allowed to take off
their costumes or make up like all day
so it would be like hours and hours and
hours
um I believe like uh you know the guy
that played the Tin Man he couldn't even
sit like if he wanted to rest like they
had to kind of lean him against a board
kind of thing so uh so there was that
too
uh also the Scarecrow mask that Ray
Bolger had to wear like left
um kind of like weird imprints or like
scars on his face that were reportedly
like left there for a year so there's
that
also Toto the dog was played by a little
uh cairn terrier a female dog actually
uh whose name was Terry
now during the filming the dog got
stepped on by one of the winkies and a
poor little terry like had her little
paw broken during the during the
production so she actually had to be uh
replaced with another dog for like a
month until she got better
um and I think somebody mentioned this
earlier too but the story goes that the
owner of Toto like got more money for
the movie than most of the little people
that played the munchkins so there was
that too
um also there was another thing too
about it because this was shot in
Technicolor it was one of the first
movies to
to have that
um you kind of had to the set had to be
like super super bright so you had to
have like a lot of lights on to get that
real Vivid color
and because of all the lighting they
didn't have like nowadays they have kind
of stuff that will cool the lights off
and everything but back then they didn't
have that so um on the set the
temperatures would be like way like
above 100 degrees and like I said you
have like these people these very very
heavy very very hot costumes so you know
there was some problems there as well
with people like [ __ ] fainting and
[ __ ] like that because you didn't just
have you know Bert Lara as a Cowardly
Lion and stuff but you had like all the
winkies and you had like the guys that
were playing like the winged monkeys and
stuff like that who had these full-on
fur body suits and they're like in these
[ __ ]
you know and they're spending hours and
hours like on this set where it's just
kind of like 100 like 120 degrees and a
lot of them were like [ __ ]
passing out and getting heat stroke and
[ __ ] like that
all right so let's talk about
I don't know where Tom went to he's been
gone for like a long time
but he maybe went downstairs to like
[ __ ] start some
what's up Pokey what are you talking
about
Pookie's talking over there
she probably wants me to open the closet
door
murder Hornet said I'm gonna make a
surprise visit to Tom's house well it's
not a surprise now you just told us
Pat says good God were they trying to
kill the entire main cast of Wizard of
Oz
it kind of seems like that because like
I said I think
this kind of [ __ ] was like really
endemic uh back then because I really
don't think they gave much of a [ __ ]
like about the actors I think like Tom
said I think they've thought of them as
just very interchangeable and it's like
hey there's other ones out there you
know if you don't want to do something
so everybody just kind of did it and
they didn't really have like I said they
weren't unionized at that time they
didn't really have any protections and
they didn't really seem to
you know they they didn't seem to have
any concept of like hey this makeup has
like you know has toxic chemicals in it
and can cause all kind of stuff they
were basically like look we just want to
get this movie out and make some money
off it so just quit your crying it was
just kind of like that you know it just
really did seem like that I think some
of the crew members like from what I
could determine I think some of the like
people that did like worked behind the
scenes like you know painting sets or
like doing lights or whatever I think
they were unionized so they had like a
modicum more production than the actors
did but actors were just seen as like I
said very interchangeable so they really
didn't seem to care
like uh what they put them through so
there's a lot of stories like that like
from the Golden Days Golden Era of
Hollywood you know what I mean
um okay so let's talk about the 1996
island of Dr Moreau
now as I said there are so many like
[ __ ] crazy stories about the making
of this [ __ ] that there's a whole
documentary about it I think it's called
Lost Souls it might still be on shutter
it was for a long time I don't know if
it's still on there or not
but
so like I said okay so the island of Dr
Moreau has been made into a movie like
several times this was the 1996 version
that we're talking about that was like
the most famous uh [ __ ] show
so the guy that was being like the main
headliner in it was Val Kilmer
now he had just been in Tombstone from
1993 he played Doc Holliday actually we
just covered we just uh talked about
Tombstone a couple weeks ago and uh I
will say like Val Kilmer
I've heard a lot of stories about like
what he's like behind the scenes but he
was actually great in Tombstone he was a
great Doc Holiday
um I think he'd also been in Batman
Forever too
uh so he's in it he was supposed to be
like the headliner and also they got
Marlon Brando who's gonna be Dr Moreau
obviously
um they were kind of wanting him to be
they wanted him to do like a colonel
Kurtz type of situation like from
apocalypse now that's kind of what they
were hoping for I guess
um so they also had farooza balk was in
this uh David thulis who I love he's
like a British actor
he was in it as well
um and they just thought well this is
going to be great it's a great cast it's
a great story it's been you know uh you
know adapted to film it's an H.G Wells
story it's been adapted to film several
times before it's always like very
successful so you know it's gonna be a
good time
but
um not so much like even before they had
filmed a [ __ ] frame of this movie
there were problems
now initially
um the part that Val Kilmer like the
main part was supposed to be Bruce
Willis
but the thing that happened like back in
the 90s
Bruce Willis was married to Demi Moore
and there was like a big huge um you
know I don't know how many of you guys
are old enough to remember this but
there was like a huge Scandal about the
divorce and it was like this big [ __ ]
deal it was on all the tabloids and
everything like that
so Bruce Willis was having some personal
issues and he didn't want to do the
movie
so they basically recast Val Kilmer in
that role
now Val Kilmer when he came on
he said well I'm only going to shoot 60
of what Bruce Willis was supposed to
shoot like for whatever reason that's
kind of what he came at it from
so basically they're like well okay well
we can't do that because you're kind of
like the main role so we're gonna have
to put you into a smaller role like he
was supposed to play Edward prent uh
prendrick who I think is like the main
character's name
and they're like well you can't just
shoot 60 of that so we'll put you in a
smaller role so they change they
transferred him to like another role
which is Mr Montgomery who is the
assistant to Dr Moreau
now
James Woods who initially was supposed
to play Mr Montgomery he ended up
getting forced out of the movie because
that was his part and now Val Kilmer now
they were pushing him into that so James
was like okay well [ __ ] it
now what ends up happening with this
in the original Source novel uh
prendrick it was kind of like the main
character he's like a sailor and he
washes ashore
and he's the one that like sees all the
crazy [ __ ] that's going on on this on
the island right
now what they decided to do though was
that they were going to make that
character like a un inspector like
instead of a sailor which for reasons I
don't really know and everyone was like
okay that seems like a dumb idea
whatever
um so as I said Richard Stanley was the
original director on this and very
famously this was the last movie he did
for a very very long time because
because of the [ __ ] show that this
became he was just kind of like yeah he
just kind of went a little bit crazy
so the thing about the thing that's kind
of sad about this too is that Richard
Stanley had been wanting to make the
island of Dr Moreau for like a really
really long time I mean he had just
spent like years working on it and
thinking about it and it's like he
um had actually like spent a lot of his
own money like to get a studio to like
talk to him about it
and it was kind of like his biggest
movie it was going to be his biggest
movie that he'd ever made
um I mean he got like finally new line
Cinema who wasn't like a huge you know
they weren't like a huge Studio or
anything like that but it's like they
were the ones that were gonna like put
the money up and so he finally got them
to do it and you know to take a chance
on him and whatnot
but
um there were kind of like even from the
beginning there were kind of rumors
swirling around that he was going to be
replaced possibly by Roman Polanski it
was a lot more uh experienced obviously
so what Richard Stanley did he said well
I'm gonna go meet with Marlon Brando
because I figured Marlon Brando was like
a really big star
and if I can get him on my side then
maybe I'll have more pull like with the
studio because they won't want to like
piss Marlon Brando off right so because
you know he wasn't as famous like
Richard Stanley wasn't as famous so he
needed somebody more famous like on his
side to kind of like go to bat for him
right
so he so Richard Stanley goes to a
meeting with Marlon Brando at Marlon
Brando's house in the Hollywood Hills
um and then like they
there's this whole story I don't know
how true this is but there's a whole
story that Richard Stanley who was
actually I believe he was a Wiccan uh at
the time that this was going on
he actually brought a warlock like a
British warlock
um to
help him like convince Marlon Brando to
like come over to his side and like you
know get on board with him to like to
make this movie
so somehow like all of this worked
Marlon Brando is like you know okay fine
I'm gonna go to bat for you so the
studio is like okay fine we won't
replace you whether or not they were
going to really I'm not really sure
but they said okay you can go ahead and
do it so Richard Stanley is basically
like okay no I got Marlon Brando we're
gonna make this movie it's gonna be
awesome
now one day before the shoot was gonna
start
Marlon Brando's daughter committed
suicide
obviously Marlon Brando is not going to
be uh you know in any frame of mind to
be filming a movie
after that happened so there was uh you
know automatically like a really big
delay like while they waited for him to
like get through his grief or whatever
um also there was
um basically like Richard Stanley was
like okay well we can shoot around him
for like a little while like they kind
of shot all the stuff that he wasn't in
so they started doing that
but a couple days later a hurricane hit
the set
and uh basically swept most of it out
into the ocean so there was that too
uh so they had to stop again for like a
very long time
Richard Stanley at this point uh as well
as the executives at Newland Cinema are
starting to think maybe this project is
cursed and maybe we should just like cut
our [ __ ] losses
um but they they kind of like soldiered
on with it right
so they did finally manage to like start
shooting again
but then uh the director and Val Kilmer
started getting into confrontations
Val Kilmer on the set of this has been
called a prep school bully that's a
quote that gets thrown a lot around a
lot
um and Richard Stanley I mean if for
those of you know he's kind of like
famous for being
a very unorthodox unorthodox kind of
director he's not real he's not a
stickler he's just kind of like he's a
very um what's the word that I'm looking
for he's just kind of more uh
instinctive you know what I mean he's
not real worried about like you know
doing things he's like we're just gonna
go by go with the flow kind of thing Val
Kilmer uh was not having that because
Val Kilmer really wanted to do things in
a particular way like in his own method
kind of way and he was really not jiving
with this whole like more laid-back kind
of thing that Richard Stanley was doing
so they got in a lot of um you know
altercations
so uh you know so that caused a lot of
uh you know rewrites and shooting delays
and like Val Kilmer would have some
tantrums and [ __ ] like that
and because their relationship had so
soured that
um you know a lot of the crew obviously
you know they have to come to work every
day and like get into this like kind of
toxic environment and that was like not
fun for anybody either
um and this other actor named Rob Morrow
he came in uh to play the prendrick
character who Val Kilmer had First
supposed to be played but obviously Val
Kilmer said I'm only doing 60 so they
gave him the smaller role so Rob Morrow
comes in and he basically thought that
the whole like situation on the set was
so shitty that he didn't even want to be
on this [ __ ] movie anymore so he
called his agent is like please get me
the [ __ ] out of this contract I don't
even want to like [ __ ] do it because
it's awful
so um his agent was successful in
getting him to do that
so he was only there for like three days
and he was just like [ __ ] that I'm out
um so yeah so basically the studio are
kind of like okay this is really really
going sideways um they'd already given
up like 40 40 million dollars like the
budget and they've only shot like a few
days worth of footage and everybody is
just being like a [ __ ] baby about
everything and everybody's fighting
um you know and part of the set had like
had to be rebuilt because the hurricane
and all this other kind of [ __ ]
so basically they come in and they took
everything that Richard Stanley had shot
so far
and they threw it all out everything
that he had shot
and uh then they sent him a fax and
fired him they said we're just gonna
start all over
from frame one
uh and at this point Richard Stanley uh
he was basically like
he pretty much had a nervous breakdown
um he started uh
he started trying to like sabotage the
set
like he would go to
[Music]
um
he would basically go and anything that
he had to do with the movie like
storyboards or anything like that he
just like put him through the shredder
and he [ __ ] it all up
um any anything that he had like left
over from the production he just
destroyed it and he also got a bunch of
people that either were extras on the
film or actually were kind of like
locals that lived in the area he
actually got a bunch of them to go and
like [ __ ]
sabotage the set you know what I mean
like and he got some of the like
Aboriginal people that from where around
where they were filming he's like I want
you to like go into the set and like put
some like weird kind of
weird like Stone arranged like some
Blair Witch kind of [ __ ] so everybody
like this was pretty Blair Witch but you
know what I'm talking about so he would
put like all these weird stones on the
ground so it would freak everyone out so
they would think that like they'd you
know they were like putting a hex on him
and [ __ ] so he told him to do that kind
of [ __ ]
also after all of that he ended up
wandering off into basically like the
rainforest in Australia or whatever and
just lived there by himself like for a
while
um out there like smoking pot or
whatever because he just couldn't deal
with it anymore
um but yeah so he would basically uh
also The Story Goes that after he did
that he came back onto the set of island
of Dr Moreau and like him and like some
of the other like locals from the area
like they snuck onto the set and
pretended they were extras so The Story
Goes that you can actually still see him
in the background of some of the scenes
because they didn't catch him so there
was that like he was very very mad that
his kind of passion project had been
taken away from him
so the director that they gave the movie
to was John frankenheimer uh who also
did prophecy actually the one about the
mutated I actually like this movie I
like probably too yeah but yeah that's
the same thing he's done other things
too but that alien came in a little bit
later and blew it away but it was
prophecy was all over fagoria magazine
for a while
good movie for its time we just see yeah
we did a review of it not too long ago
and they left the two-legged fish
hanging remember that they did they
showed a scene where the [ __ ]
two-legged little fish in their
laboratory ran by and you like what the
[ __ ] was that they just like well you
think I think we talked about that like
because I was like what happened with
that I was curious about the like little
fish with you yes I got tall they ran
across it and they were like that's like
they never did revisit that no situation
that was that was there was there was a
sequel right there
of what happened you know what I mean
you could have made a sequel based on
that
what happens yeah because I'm kind of
curious about that what happens when
that fish grows up
and it spawns he he becomes he becomes
the the fish man from the shape of water
no and has sex with the jazz or the
creature
Creature from the back again El padrone
said I thought you meant the prophecy no
that was a different movie the one with
Christopher Walken that's not the one
we're talking about yeah we're talking
about the one that's just called
prophecy is from 1978 it's like a
mutated it's like an Eco or Eco horror
mutated bear got a hold of some yeah
Mercury and no it wasn't just Mercury it
was some other it was mostly Mercury
mostly Mercury and some kind of Biotech
that got mixed in with it in the [ __ ]
Bear yeah yeah
the pregnant bear got a hold of it and
then this mutated bear popped out of the
the mama
Pokey ran around killing everything
scared the [ __ ] out of me when I was a
kid because I was going to Sequoia
National and Redwood forest with Lois
all the time my aunt Lois
and there's a scene where the kids in a
sleeping bag trying to jump away and
that bear comes and goes boom and the
sweet sleeping bag goes flying and hits
the tree and explodes at a [ __ ] Cloud
a [ __ ] time god scene will never not
make me laugh it is so I saw that [ __ ]
and I was like oh that's it you know
what's crazy like when
um at mannequins uh you know he has
that's the club we go to in Fisher new
um he has like a
kind of a video that he shows that has
like all these just little clips from
horror movies and it has that already in
there and it's like at that it always
makes you laugh every single time that's
[ __ ] hilarious sleeping bag goes
flying you could tell there's like
somebody in it or a thing man shape and
it hits a tree so hard it blows up into
a [ __ ] feathers because you know it's
so awesome there's a kid in it is that
70s yeah I was a little kid because
that's 70s you know what I mean and so
the sleeping bag is so [ __ ] they have
feathers in it you know
boom like that and it was like a little
kid and the little kid was probably like
my age you know what I mean and I was
like oh man it's so great that movie
stooped to that level where they're
killing children yeah
they didn't give them enough safe now
they killed children and I was going and
[ __ ] going to the Redwood Forest up
in California all the time you know I'm
[ __ ] scaring the [ __ ] out of me
never saw a bear there I see bear here
all the time walking in the
[ __ ] garage looking at me hey
what's up sweet little black bear you
know going through your garbage yeah hey
how you doing that [ __ ] on the ground
right here my [ __ ] right here
at least they asked yeah [ __ ] came in
one one night from the club this is at
the other place it was even closer to
[ __ ] the city
I was going up in the [ __ ] driveway
and there was a bear [ __ ] sitting on
its ass with its hands like this like in
front of the garage just sitting there
in front of the garage watching me pull
in and he goes and he was huge bigger
than a man yeah it was a bigger and he's
just like oh [ __ ] he rolls over and
[ __ ] just walks off oh [ __ ] he must
have been a [ __ ] 400 pound black bear
yeah standing up on his back legs it
must have been about six feet tall
probably I mean that's [ __ ] up oh you
should get in trouble come down here
what are you doing
get down good girl
she knows what get down is and stop and
yeah
no she went up there and she's [ __ ]
with my uh phone because my phone's on
the charger over there yeah so she's
like over there [ __ ] with it she'll
climb up on my chest I'm gonna sleep and
then I'll read what what what I'll look
down and her face is like right here
hey Daddy what you doing are you awake
you like are you awake yeah I'm awake
yeah
I'm scared you're scared yeah I'm scared
it's gonna be okay
she woke me up other morning like
jumping up on the side on the um on the
little nightstand yeah and throwing
something off of it she was mad because
her little treat plate was empty yeah
she gets scared man if it's too quiet
she gets scared she checks on you okay
you guys still alive I'm scared
a poor baby
all right so
by the way chicken is in okay and I made
um
cheese sauce for macaroni
well damn it's gonna have macaroni and
cheese that sounds really good yeah made
it out of the damn Neato butter and that
cheese powder
it's good too yeah that's good I tried
it put the macaroni in it I'm sure I had
leftover macaroni I cooked earlier today
oh is that the bow tie pasta no oh it's
elbows oh cause I'm out of bow tie okay
so I've got some elbows for my servant
and I had some left over and I made
macaroni out of macaroni and cheese
we'll say yeah it's good yeah
so yeah we got distracted talking about
John Frank and I would have barbecue
chicken and macaroon macaroni and cheese
barbecue chicken thigh it's in there
like 250 going about a an hour so and
I'll go check it and I might turn it up
towards the end it's just a it's thought
I'm just kind of slow cooking it
marinated and everything yummy you're
good
yeah so we got distracted talking about
John frankenheimer so John frankenheimer
comes on
to do island of Dr morale
um he didn't really want to do it like
they asked him but he's like I love it I
don't love it but they said hey we'll
give you a contract for a three picture
deal and we'll give you like a [ __ ]
out of money I don't know how much it
was but it was a lot and he's like um
all right so he decided to do it I mean
he was kind of like a more of a safe bet
I guess because Richard Stanley like I
said is a little bit
you know he's he's an awesome director
but he's like a little bit
weird he's like a little bit of quirky
you know what I mean
so they figured this guy would kind of
like come in and write the ship I
suppose
um problem was John frankenheimer comes
in Val Kilmer kind of started to behave
but then Marlon Brando started acting
like a douche
oh he would basically come in and just
started like acting like a total
pre-madonna he's like I'm just gonna be
in my really nice trailer for hours and
hours
um you know and he's like oh and by the
way I'm not even gonna bother reading
the script or memorizing my lines or
anything like that
I'm just gonna like sit here in my thing
and it's like yeah call me if you want
but I'm not gonna bother like putting in
any effort because he just decided he
was going to be that way I suppose
so basically John frankenheimer was like
okay well
um Can somebody like read Marlon Brando
his lines like through like an earpiece
like while they're shooting the movie
because he couldn't be bothered to like
memorize the [ __ ]
um so yeah also Marlon Brando wanted
more the scripture written because he
became like he got like established this
really close friendship with
um this other guy that was in the movie
Nelson de la Rosa who's like who was at
the time was like the world's smallest
man she was like a little person and for
some reason Marlon Brando like really
got into this little dude so he wanted
his part to be bigger so he told him to
like rewrite the script like to make his
part bigger so there was that uh John
Frank and I were was like okay fine uh
we'll do some of that but he wouldn't do
all of it
um also Marlon Brando had the idea that
he wanted to turn into a dolphin at the
end of the movie
and John frankenheimer said no
absolutely not absolutely not although
how [ __ ] funny would that have been
what was the name of this movie again
island of doctor oh yeah that one yeah
okay yes you could you could you could
turn into a damn
yeah I mean in the context of the story
it's not as crazy as it sounds just like
out of the blue like that they were
turning into animals they were turned
into animals as they went he'd be a
pretty chubby dolphin I actually liked
that movie
some people were back on that movie I
like color out of space too
yeah I mean and well that's the thing
like Richard Stanley he had his cage he
was so soured on yeah from making this
movie that he basically retired from
Hollywood he yeah he didn't come back I
don't think he made another movie until
color out of space yep I got him I got I
got color out of space I gotta get I had
to get out of the doctor tomorrow
I would be curious to see it again
because I remembered I don't remember
that much about it like I don't remember
it being great but I also don't remember
it being like laughably terrible it's
had ferozan and she was still real cute
yeah
Ferris was standing behind me in line
getting coffee one time I didn't even
know it Ginny had to tell me afterwards
yeah we saw we were at that uh horror
convention yeah because I saw her like I
immediately recognized her she didn't
really I didn't recognize it that was
like a couple years I was like man
because yeah she was she was standing
right behind you in line yes I don't
even know
yeah she didn't look all that much
different to me she did
I just expected her to look like
something out of the movie well now but
that's not what she looked like no she's
not gonna look like that yeah Danny
Rowling said zero CGI whatsoever in the
island of Dr Moreau which is awesome and
great makeup and costumes unlike the
original yeah
um I don't yeah maybe that's something
we should like looking to do and like
see all the versions of it that might be
I like it in comparison I kind of it
reminded me at the time of of a high a
higher Tech version of of
of uh
not uh not wolfen uh the howling kind of
like the howling one yeah that's kind of
what it reminded me of
because there were some transformation
scenes in it and stuff
it wasn't just werewolves though you
know it was people turn it into Panthers
and cats and monkeys you know it was
pretty cool
now I kind of want to watch it to be
honest
yeah you kind of want to watch it Marlon
Brando was just being crazy as [ __ ] I
mean he was just being crazy in the [ __ ]
okay because he's being himself
basically you could tell and he had a
little miniature person that was only
this tall that's who I was talking about
yeah and he kept jacking off and he's
like stop it don't do that
[Laughter]
he started jerking off you need to stop
it
okay see now I have to see I don't
remember that you don't remember that
yeah no like I said yeah I was probably
like a kid but yeah well I wasn't a kid
but he had a little pet human that was
about that big yeah that's the actor
that I was just talking about he
couldn't stop jerking off
[Laughter]
sounds like a personal problem it was
because it was so small it was a person
it was so small it was like a monkey
yeah so it had it kind of like a
monkey's intelligence I guess
said Marlon Brando also wanted a talking
suitcase as a part of his character in
Superman
and that was a long time before this
well and Brandon wanted that well that
might have that might have made sense in
in in in in the comments what are you
talking about Noah wouldn't have
Marlon Brando played Superman's Dad yeah
back on the alien planet yeah he might
have had like what they're talking about
a talking suitcase they're talking about
a laptop
right but
in the context of 1978 or whenever that
movie came out I don't think that would
have worked out so yeah Marlon Brown is
being smart man he's saying no no
[ __ ] uh Jarrell would have had a
[ __ ] uh a laptop computer is what
they're talking about
a little talking briefcase you open it
up and it talks and then you do stuff
with it and yeah super computers what
he's talking about
got it I still think in 1978 that would
have looked really really dumb
depends on how they did it
the cool thing about the original
Superman is that
it's always better if you're gonna do
like a sci-fi movie like don't try to
take technology of nowadays and just
like extrapolate like five or ten years
in the future make it like completely
yeah different so I did it so yeah
that's what I was gonna say that's why I
think the crystals were a good idea
because that's not tied to any
particular era it doesn't look
particularly dated it looks like
completely alien technology and I think
that's really what you need to strive
for when you're doing sci-fi because it
holds up because it holds up if you see
it like many years later if you just try
to do you know something it's like you
know it's now it's like you see
something from
you know that was made in I don't know
like the 70s and they're like ooh in the
future of 1985 and everybody still has
like really shitty like [ __ ]
wireframe computer technology and it's
like obviously they had better [ __ ] than
that like in whatever year it was oh
it's the year 2000 I'm like yeah we have
better [ __ ] than that in 2000. those
first two Superman with Christopher
Reeves are [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
phenomenal Richard daughter and the
Donner cut the second one's good too I
got that one also
and um it's a it's a little bit
different than the than the theatrical
release
but no it's a good idea that the crystal
technology that allowed that allowed
Superman to talk to his dad and you know
his dad explains early on that all my
knowledge all my mind has been stored on
these crystals you know what I mean so
you could access me basically
and uh you couldn't do that with any
known technology you know of of the
1970s so you had to say it had to be
magic basically it's a magic crystals
magic crystals had stored his soul so
you can interact with him in lifetime
that that's great that way you can have
[ __ ] Brando showed up and then the
daughter cut Brando's in it
he does a couple other scenes in the
donor cut
I don't think that was in the in the
normal cut of the of Superman too I
think I think he they didn't want to pay
his fee so I think they cut him out
yeah because [ __ ] yeah he wanted too
much I think but if you get the daughter
cut he's in it
they're like [ __ ] Brenda we're gonna put
his ass back in that [ __ ] he's dead you
know okay well yeah now what's he gonna
now he can't yeah well his mistake can
still see what I got yes but you know
what I mean yeah they probably reached
an agreement Zach says uh apparently
Brando and the little dude were the
inspiration for Dr Evil and mini me in
Austin Powers probably right yeah that
makes sense makes sense and Mr 80 it
said no an actual Talking suitcase
the actual talkies I'd have to see what
it is he's talking about so not like
just like not a laptop just like an
actual talking
how was Superman's dad have that
well that's what we were talking that's
what we're said that's what we're
talking about that's a dumb [ __ ]
there's nothing like a suitcase there
also what the [ __ ] like I don't know man
Marlon Brando what kind of [ __ ] drugs
was he on it's like I'm gonna turn into
dolphin at the end of this movie [ __ ]
off with that [ __ ] off
Pat Uh says something I like the nuclear
football
the president carries her out
Pat says unfortunately Colorado space
didn't do so well and Richard Stanley
got soured on making movies yet again at
least that's what I heard which is a
shame because I really liked coloring
it's not a bad movie I didn't like it as
much as Mandy yeah like I know that's
not the same director but it still had
Nicolas Cage in it and it was kind of
you know Lovecraft that's a decent movie
El pedrina said I still have an original
Garbage Pail Kid sticker I think I have
one somewhere too matter of fact but I
can't remember which one it is
um Zach says Blade Runner being set in
2019 I wish the 2020s had that kind of
tech but then again we're getting kind
of scary close to it in some ways yeah
but she had to read the book and and
then the movie makes a lot more sense
because in the book it's after a nuclear
Holocaust
and um a lot of the technology that they
were using was recycled
so it was 2019 but they had stuff from
the 1980s in the 1990s strapped onto
cars and merged together to make a new
product you know they they were
recycling stuff which is why it looks so
[ __ ] weird trying to steampunky
looking in the movie
there wasn't new products really
and only losers were on Earth everybody
else had left in the book
yeah
okay you're just like sitting there
blinking
that's all I gotta say about it oh okay
I didn't know you didn't read the book a
long time ago I don't remember that much
about it
no Deckard Deckard and everybody else in
the replicants and everything they were
just those are the people that couldn't
pass the physical they had to be stuck
on on Earth everybody else had gone to
the colonies and it is the same universe
as alien it's the same it's the same
universe basically
just go according to Ridley Scott
it's the same future his future is
always the same future
Pat says at this point Marlon Brando
wasn't so much an actor more like an
extortionist
and then Zach said I read an article
about Brandon as a parent eating
disorder and was actually really
depressing and I felt really bad for him
so yeah there's I gotta clean that up
though what I just said because that
sounds awful funny
the book was written by dicks so a lot
of stuff out of the book Really Scott
had nothing to do with that but when
Ruthie Scott made the Blade Runner movie
an alien one
it's the same future
in those two movies
which is uh and it's not quite like the
book but you know that's uh that that
kind of cleaned that up El padrini said
Blade Runner was uh Wes Harrison Ford a
robot I always heard yeah he was a
replicant I mean there's still a debate
about that he was I'm pretty sure yeah
really really Scott said he was I've
seen arguments on both sides but I mean
how else how else how else would a gaff
known about that [ __ ] unicorn the
Unicorn if it's got the Unicorn scene in
it and the scene where he walks away
from Rachel and says somebody would and
you see that his eyes are glowing in the
[ __ ] mirror reflection he's a replica
the real Blade Runner he's he's
replacing he replaced the Blade Runner
that got shot
at the Tyrell Corporation doing the void
comp test on [ __ ] Leon
they shot that guy so they made another
Blade Runner a [ __ ] replicant Blade
Runner to go after him a different Nexus
model
his life started on the park bench in
the beginning of the movie that's where
that's where that decorates and he's a
replica of another Blade Runner that got
killed
easy so he goes back into the they sent
him back into the into the uh apartment
of the of another dead Blade Runner
but no he's he's he's rep
yeah Pat said it depends who you ask
Ridley's God insisted that he was
everyone else says he wasn't
murder Hornet said the Unicorn at the
end they deleted the scene that explains
that yeah he if it's if if the movie's
got the unicorn in it he's a replica and
that's how he has a child with Rachel
later on in in the second Blade Runner
movie in 2049 yeah which they were two
special replicant models
Rachel and and and and and and and and a
[ __ ]
what was his name a [ __ ] um
not Derek what was his name of the
[ __ ] um
the blade the name of the Blade Runner
that Harrison Ford was playing what was
his name um Deckard yeah
they had a child together
a replicant child which supposedly
wasn't supposed to happen but the
corporations were that were involved and
it wanted that to happen they wanted
replacements for human real ones the
ones that could have sex and reproduce
so they could take over
that was eventually how that went no
he's a replicant
yeah how else do you how else do you
hang from the side of a building with
two broken fingers
you know he did a bunch of stuff in
there that
in that final scene that a human
couldn't have done
jumping from one building to the next
uh El padrino said what version of the
movie is better in your opinion
of of all of the versions of Blade
Runner that last one I think was called
the director's cut
I think
yeah I get them all confused yeah I've
seen all I've seen all the versions
that final one that has the has all the
restored see not all the receipt scenes
are restored there's a scene you can
find it on YouTube
where Deckard goes to the hospital and
talks to the Blade Runner that Leon shot
in the beginning of the movie and he
they got him at a damn plastic tube and
they're talking to each other he's
paralyzed he can breathe that's it and
there and he's watching his things on a
screen it's kind of like
kind of like the little hibernation
capsule that Wayland was in in
Prometheus it's kind of like that and
he's talking to him
about the replicas
and asked him if he ever had sex with a
replicate and [ __ ]
that that that guy told him what it was
like to have sex with a replica before
you killed her that kind of stuff it was
weird [ __ ]
and you see they cut a bunch of stuff
out
you were going to find out that Tyrell
was a replicate the one that [ __ ]
what's his name crushed
and the real Tyrell was in was in was in
cryogenic storage kind of like Wayland
was he was awake but he was down in a
Subterranean chamber his replicant was
running the program was running the show
for him and he was down in the basement
the real Tyrell and suspended animation
but he could talk from it from suspended
animation
and directed the other one
and he was going to stay down there
until they had a cure for his disease
that he that he had and he wanted
immortality they were going to make him
a new body and transfer his
Consciousness into it
and then he'd re-emerge as Tyrell he'd
be immortal like a god that's why it's
shaped like a pyramid he's the pharaoh
the pharaoh's surviving death
in eternal life that was the theme of
all that
which is the dream of all oligarchs is
to live forever
all right you want to talk about one
more movie and then we'll wrap it up
because we're at three hours okay so you
know like I said I wanted to talk about
fitzgeraldo because Klaus kinky
you guys would love to talk about class
kids need so fitzgeraldo this came out
in 1982 very very famous uh [ __ ] show
because not only was it Klaus Kinski but
it's also Verner Herzog uh which if
you've seen the documentary my best
fiend uh the two of them work together a
lot because they did make some brilliant
movies but the two of them had
let's call it a contentious relationship
just that's it's an understatement I
mean they pretty much loathed each other
I feel like uh Klaus Kinski who we've
talked about before because we've
covered crawl space and you know
Nosferatu like his version of Nosferatu
um was a noted uh crazy person so you
know so there was that
and apparently like no one could stand
to be around him
so basically
um both of them had worked together like
I said several times they worked um
famously on Aguirre the wrath of God and
Klaus Kinski
uh apparently on that the story goes on
that set he actually like had a tantrum
and said I'm not gonna act anymore and
Werner Herzog held a gun to his head and
made him do the next scenes like while
he was pointing again at him like he was
gonna shoot him so you know like I said
a little a little bit of a toxic
relationship a little bit uh so so yeah
so they're making fitzgeraldo which I
believe came out in 1982.
now it wasn't just Werner Herzog that
had a problem with Klaus Kinski
apparently everybody that ever met Klaus
Kinski had a problem with Klaus Kinski
because he was apparently insufferable
um a lot of the indigenous people around
where they were filming they shot this
in Peru the movie is if you've never
seen it it's actually like quite a
brilliant movie but it's about
um a guy who's Big like kind of quixotic
dream I guess is to build an opera house
but like in the middle of the jungle
so yeah so and he's playing that kind of
character so they shot in Peru and
they're you know a lot of indigenous
people that lived around there were like
extras or on the crew or things like
that and they
um
they didn't take too kindly to Klaus
Kinski um it's basically he was just
acting like crazy all the time and he
was just like constantly screaming and
having tantrums and whatnot and uh
basically a chief from a local tribe
offered to murder him yeah like went up
to Werner Herzog and said hey do you
want me to kill him for you yeah
um and apparently Werner was kind of
like thinking about it for a minute
he's probably wondering if I tell this
guy to kill him out here and this
jurisdiction will they am I guilty he
probably did that I mean I would imagine
it probably like crossed his mind yeah
as far as I know because we've talked
about Klaus Kinski before because we've
talked about some of his other movies
and you know difficult to work with
doesn't even cover it it's crazy he is
yeah and like not even like a little bit
cute quirky crazy he's like legit crazy
he evidently was having sex with his own
daughter that's what we heard yeah
that's what he heard no homie to it but
that's what the allegation was not
that's not
um not in the stuff not Natasha they're
not one of the other ones
he had two of them
any wasn't he kind of like hinting that
he did
I'm not sure like I said he says like
all kind of like he says weird [ __ ] like
he's dead now I think yeah he was crazy
he was like a crazy person he wasn't
normal
no like big time no
uh and I think drugs were wrong too
maybe I think that [ __ ] was high
a lot
yeah and I'm sure that didn't help yeah
he was a diva and high a lot and crazy
I can't imagine like um oh El pedrini
said gotta go but I'll catch you guys
later thanks for posting I'll keep
following thank you very much thank you
very much
um we're glad to see you in the chat
yeah we're looking for more patrons
great
oh did you do the uh commercials
commercials man oh well I'll show like
one before the end so just you know are
they gonna check out well we just got
like one more thing to talk about this
this is what happens okay do you know
what I mean
um I'm gonna check the chicken in a
minute well I know okay so yeah
so it wasn't just Klaus Kinski being a
diva like I said I can't imagine being
that narcissistic like being that being
that up your own ass that you really
like feel like the whole world revolves
around you and like everybody just has
to [ __ ]
you know just acquiesce to your needs I
just don't understand there were lots of
those I know but it's like that every
time I meet somebody like that I'm
always because I've met some people like
that too I'm just like what
I don't know I don't understand that
mindset at all narcissism I've never
felt that in my entire life
so I don't really get it but yeah so it
wasn't just that but
um there's also there's actually like um
a documentary about I mean other than my
best fiend which is you know more
specifically about Berner Herzog and
Klaus Kinsey like their relationship
with one another but there's actually
another documentary which is called
burden of dreams and it's specifically
about the making of fitzgeraldo so in
the um kind of behind the scenes shots
from that documentary
there are a bunch of like shots of you
know just there's kind of poisonous
snakes everywhere it's Peru right um so
they're like in the grass and they're
falling out of trees and [ __ ] like that
so um basically one of the crew members
actually did get bitten on the foot by
one of the snakes and they're super
super venomous right
um and basically I guess they were kind
of out in the middle of nowhere
and apparently this crew member knew how
venomous the snakes were and knew
perhaps that they wouldn't be able to
get to medical help in time maybe
so apparently this person decided they
were going to
cut their own foot off
to keep the Venom from spreading any
further
so this person got bit by a venomous
snake on his foot and then he cut off
his own foot with a chainsaw
because
why not I guess like that's way better
than just
I mean I hope he used to tourniquet
I don't really know but yeah he did live
as far as I know but holy [ __ ]
can you imagine like it's like oh this
venomous snake bit my foot so I'm just
gonna cut my own foot off with a
chainsaw but that's what happened that's
what happened chicken's looking good
okay
um
also Jason Robards was in this movie
and he was actually cast originally like
in the title role of like of fitzgeraldo
and he was actually in Peru for several
months uh filming the movie in 1979 but
he got dysentery uh four months into the
filming and during that time lost
40 pounds uh from the disease
so uh so basically yeah
now so he so actually Kinski wasn't
supposed to play like the main role
Jason Robards was but he got dysentery
and lost where he founds and so you know
he wasn't on the movie anymore so they
actually got uh Kinski on there
um and Herzog actually did say later on
that he thought Klaus Kinski was better
in the role that Jason Robards would
have been but I guess we'll never know
will we
also uh Werner Herzog apparently had
hired about a thousand extras who like I
said were indigenous to the area
and um basically treating them like crap
uh they put the Thousand extras in
Barracks pretty much
uh there wasn't enough food for
everybody like they didn't feed
everybody uh and actually like one of
the extras died of malaria
um
and that went on for like six months
because it was a very very long shoot
and like I said it was in the middle of
the [ __ ] jungle uh also the camp was
attacked by another tribe uh from around
there so there's that
and uh basically like after
so this other tribe attacks the crew of
this movie
and one of the guys that was working on
the movie got shot with an arrow it was
like a five foot long arrow and it went
like up like through his throat for real
like he lived
right but yeah like you're just working
on a movie and you get shot before the
[ __ ] five foot Arrow like right
through your throat so that happened too
so yeah so arrow through the throat uh
snake bite on the foot and then cutting
off your own foot with the chainsaw you
know what I mean it was the whole thing
uh
and uh also there was at least one and
possibly two uh reportedly plane crashes
on the set
uh they're one plane crash that caused
several casualties and uh a bunch of
people had their like limbs split open
and [ __ ] like that and one person was
paralyzed uh in one of the plane crashes
so there was that also
now I mean
was it worth it probably not fitzgeraldo
is a good movie it's a great movie but
and it looks fantastic but holy [ __ ]
like so many people [ __ ] died on the
[ __ ]
um and the thing about it too is that
the cinematographer who worked on the
movie uh he actually split his hand in
half uh while he was on the set somehow
like there was an accident on the set
and he actually like I said they were
kind of far away from anything so they
had to do surgery in his hand like in
somebody's house or some [ __ ]
um and they did the surgery without any
anesthetic because like I said they were
just in somebody's house
so you know not not a fun time not a fun
time but like I said if you can find the
documentary which I think is called
burden of Dreams but I as far as I know
it's kind of difficult to find maybe
easier nowadays but it's supposedly just
about the filming of fitzgeraldo and
like all this like I said people died
people had lost limbs it was a [ __ ] show
uh if anything was a [ __ ] show so
um so I don't know I had like a couple
more movies but like I said both of the
movies that I have at the end of the
notes we've already reviewed them so I
feel like we already kind of talked
about that because I wanted to get into
those three that we talked about earlier
because those are ones that we hadn't
talked about prior but since we've
already been going for more than three
hours and you seem like
you're cooking the food and everything
like that so yeah I'm planning for the
future
plan for future we gotta eat
so I turned the chicken up to 350. so
it'd be done we'd actually probably be
done another 10 minutes
okay and I gotta do some stuff with the
uh side dishes so we should probably
like wrap it up you can wrap it up if
you wrap it up now uh you know it'll be
good
okay Mr 80 it said burn of Dreams is a
Criterion Collection release so easy to
find okay so I think for a long time
like it was kind of hard to get hold of
but I'm glad Criterion like got behind
that because like I said fitzgeraldo is
kind of like a classic so
and it was very famously like a [ __ ]
show behind the scenes so there was that
as well now this is a topic that we will
probably have to revisit because I did
want to talk about because I know Zach
was talking about doing hip like
Heaven's Gate and stuff like that and
that was another one that I wanted to
cover but you know it was hard for me to
like narrow it down so hopefully you
guys enjoyed the [ __ ] that we talked
about so I guess we'll wrap it up never
did plug never did plug anything didn't
run commercials or anything well you
know I that's we'll see that's what ends
up happening that's what ends up
happening okay I'll just run one at the
end all right I'll just run one at that
okay okay yep so all right so we are
going to wrap it up uh tomorrow we are
off but we will be back Friday night to
do the side track show which will always
be fun even though this is kind of like
a Sidetrack show anyway
so hopefully you guys had a good time
thank you everybody thank you for
listening and thank you for your super
chats and we will see you guys again on
Friday night
good night